all right scum and villainy
cantina get ready and make some noise
and welcome Kevin Smith and Mark Bernard
for Fatman
[Applause]
[Music]
Beyond
hey welcome everyone to fat man beyond
I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark
Bernard uh holy [__] kids welcome to the
end of uh 2023 I know it's not even
Christmas yet so technically the year is
not over but this is the last time we're
going to be doing it this year and so
lovely that we get to do it live if
you're watching at home we are as always
when we're live uh in Hollywood on
Hollywood Boulevard in the scum and
villainy cinaa put your hands together
so folks know you're
real they're real and they're ready to
go man we got to sold that [__] house
and [__] and we have a very special
guest kids we yeah yeah tell them
Mark uh ladies and gentlemen Robert
Downey junor RDJ is here ladies and
gentlemen no to talk about his role in
[Laughter]
Oppenheimer uh which by the way I
finally saw Oppenheimer yeah I he he is
fantastic in it if he doesn't get he I
know they'll run him for best supporting
actor he should really be run for best
actor and I'm not saying like
head-to-head with killing but I guess
that would happen but I thought he was
great anyway Robert dowy Jr is not here
look at there's that picture man that's
what he looked like an OP and [__] um no
we wish we could pull that off and [__]
no I've never met him does he go to bars
he's pretty famous for being sober now I
don't I don't know that'd be horrible if
we're like come get interviewed and at
the end of it he's like I'm off the
wagon and we're like smell the smells
come back on the circus I Ain [__]
with RDJ man I want him being RDJ I I
like him the way he's been for the last
like decade plus uh no it's not it's not
Iron Man um somebody told me though I
asked my agent at one point this is
going back when I first started
podcasting mind you I've been P
podcasting since 2007 so about 2009 or
2010 I said to my then agent very
important then
agent I said uh hey man you know I I
said we've been doing this podcast and
it's fun as [__] you know who I'd love
to talk to it's Robert Downey Jr is
there any way who do you know anybody
man maybe he'll come over and they like
he'll never come to your
house and I was like can I go to his and
I'm like
no I said what the [__] I've seen him do
interviews and [__] like that and
they're like you you are a [__] like
a very open Stoner and I'm like yeah I'm
they're like he's the other
guy and I was like so what like I
couldn't just like not smoke that day
and they're like no like your house
reeks of
weed you run the risk of pushing them
off the wagon and [__] so you know sorry
yeah but some shit's worth
it
anyway Robert Downey Jr is not our guest
no uh our guest tonight is very spe
better than [__] Robert Downey J I
mean if you ask him yeah uh I would hope
if you ask you as well I mean I like
him wow man yeah I know fuing what how
do you talk about me when I'm not around
[__] you're saying this when he's here
you don't want to know how I I know
seriously that guy uh no my son is here
tonight I
know this is the the first time he's
coming to see me do this live and I'm
sorry buddy it's going to get weird now
have you ever watched it like just seen
it like online do you ever watch the
YouTube
version um I've only seen like 10
minutes of a live stream and then my mom
cut me
off good job cuz my dad was saying bad
words um he he's like kind of a legend
in this place like an actual Legend look
at all these people showed up for
[Applause]
him does he do this at home though does
he [__] hold forth with the
microphone and be like let me tell you
some stories and
[__] uh first they're not here for me I
know this cuz if you were here and I
wasn't they'd still be here but if I was
here and you weren't they wouldn't be
here that's not true that's not true
I've seen people show us show up to
there there'd be like black man beyond
show there'd be eight people here uh
which is fine we'd all have a blast but
you know it has always been if the plane
goes down Kevin Smith an unnamed fat
black dude die in the Hills over akan
that's how they describe Jason
Muse he's been angling for that for a
long time yeah let's be honest I'm going
to die next to any podcaster it's got to
be him and [__] he's been around for a
long time um I'm trying to [__] boost
you up in front all right go for it
your dad is absolutely a legend here um
we're not just saying this
see [__] we paid that guy but everyone
else um you'll see throughout the show
as the show goes on uh what keeps it on
the rails and the most intelligent
things that are said and also some of
the funniest come from this side of the
room I think the audience agrees with me
there thank you that was probably the
second nicest thing a person has said to
my son about me what was the verse the
first your wife saying like your dad
[__] like a
demon cuz he
does uh no
no we uh the truest thing I'll ever say
to you as my son your dad [__] like a
demon do with that what you
will this is why your mom didn't want
you watch her D sh yeah uh he and I went
to the the Captain America Civil War
Premiere and I think he was like 11
going way back going way back like we
had just moved out here I had I had
gotten a job for the LA Times and with
that job came like Premier access so we
went to the to the the Civil War
Premiere we're sitting up in the stands
in the it was in the dby theater and
there's like the tears of where they put
people in the dby theater like the
floors is for the stars of the show and
the executives and the filmmakers okay
the second tier is for like people who
star in Marvel TV shows and Friends of
the family and kind of journalists and
like the third and fourth tiers are like
fans who like snuck in so I'm sitting on
the second tier and three rows in front
of me is Nathan
fillian oh some somebody just came I
know at the at the very mention of his
name every knee should bend tell me
about the filon
what um and I ad met I don't know if
there's any name that makes me come like
that where I'm like
oh like tiny
earthquakes um and so I know Nathan a
little bit because I interviewed him a
couple times as a journalist you know we
have mutual friends we had him on fat
man beyond we had on F the first show
that we used to shoot before we had the
bar before we had a bar and uh and so I
said hey buddy let's go meet Nathan he's
like really it's like yeah your mom
loves Nathan fan she'll be super jellus
jellus jellus jell your dad makes up all
sorts of funny words on the show English
is a fluid language and so uh so we walk
over and I'm like hey Nathan he's like
hey Mark how are you he's like yeah
Nathan it's my son Luke and he kneels
down cuz he's at that point 11 and he
goes Luke I'm a really big fan of your
dad's and I was like you son of a
[__] that's pretty smooth it's like you
did it you win I can never say a bad
thing about that man yeah that's very
smooth that is a and plus he's Canadian
so it was sincere Earnest as hell
American says that kids's like yeah
[__] Canadian says it kids like I
see it in your eyes I know like the the
moose in the background is like oh yeah
Canadian flag waving um well this is I I
mean honestly as I'm sitting here
thinking about it I don't think my kid
has ever come to no she's been here to
fat man beyond yeah seen her in like a
booth in the back not paying
attention I I honestly you're thinking
of my wife no cuz that sounds more like
my wife my kid actually pays attention
my wife is just like who him
whatever um I don't think the kid has I
think the kid's been here like once or
twice but never during a show huh yeah
I'm sorry so no no don't be now I have
something to throw my kid's [__] face
you know Mark's kid came and watched the
show and he can't even drink just
hanging you to watch that [__]
sober you can get drunk and watch your
father well welcome how's
college yeah he doesn't want to be home
is that right yeah I like
partying just like
Dad you're a party guy too when you go
to like the the Sano com you're the guy
that like you're out every night I I am
I am yeah but I'm not out like I used to
be no like there's a version of ComiCon
where it was like there's four parties
tonight I'm doing four parties tonight
right now there's 52y old Comic-Con
which is like I'mma Be there from like
5:30 to
7 and I'm done I got to go put my knees
to rest and that's how college kids
party right from 5:30 to 7 and
[__] the Blue Plate special at College
5:30 night till 700 in the morning like
I remember I went to to visit his dorm
room uh and I walk in and the kitchen
counter is just covered with bottles of
alcohol and I was like is there like a
vegetable anywhere in this apartment
like well vodka made of used to be
yeah um that's pretty awesome man well
welcome uh hopefully uh dad makes you
proud all night long he will cuz he
makes all of us [__] proud um if
you're
yes no no pressure no pressure
whatsoever yeah um okay uh how have you
been other have been on your best
behavior tonight best behavior uh I'm
good I'm I've I've since recovered from
my back issues yeah good fantastic we
were supposed to do this when uh the
28th of November right but we couldn't
because the back thing because my back
decided to be like hey [__] you're 52
years old go down and so I did
um and yeah and it was it was going to
be my birthday show that would have been
fun I know yeah and we were like almost
sold out and [__] like that I think we
were and JC was unhappy when I was like
man I cannot I can't I can't can you put
me in the in the in the like the hand
truck and like tilt me up and stra me
can you [__] Lecter me yeah just
sans's mask cuz it's not that kind of
show but you can strap me to a gurnie
and make me vertical I'll do it he was
like no what happens on a night like
that where we had the cancer the people
coming to the bar they're coming to the
bar anyway right hey it's b b everybody
give it up B man
hey um I have to refund 75 tickets and
send an apology message to people and
inevitably usually like two people show
up and are like what's going on they're
like guy got the best seats in the house
but the funny thing is is when that
happens I'm not here either so like the
staff has to deal with it oh [__] so we
get we all get off easy they're the ones
who have to handle that see what you did
I know I feel so bad next time I'll do a
personal message I'll do a cameo that's
like hey guys just I'm smacked up on all
kinds of drugs and I can't be vertical
now but
sorry you could done the whole show like
this I know just it'll be fine it'll be
fine oh All For You
JC so you can sell [__] blue
milk speaking of which can I have some
blue
milk b b band's back everybody can I
brag about the newest addition to the
bar [__] that's been added so the in the
corner you can't see it on camera maybe
if Andrew goes to this camera you can
kind of see it let's see can you see it
I like well we kind of have this we have
a moisture evaporator in the corner
right which is what people who live in
the desert use to suck air uh water out
of the air and they use it to drink and
do their crops so last month I took it
apart and it's now a water fountain so
our moisture evaporator works so it's a
selfs served water
station if you want to if you're you're
here and you want a water that is
[__] very cool you set the delivery
of that you're like our Water
Works was in the way of somebody who
expects to get laid off of that sort of
thing um how long it take you to make
that uh well somebody else made it for
some uh for a fan film and donated but I
think I I like 3D printed the part so it
took like a week to like design and 3D
print and then solder it all together
look at you [__] creative man you
could be sitting on resting on your
laurels with this place but you're ever
trying to improve give it up for JC kid
B man in his
bar um what you been up to what have I
been up to I uh well I
last maybe the I mean I talked about a
few episodes ago my wife shattered her
hip so for the better part of uh yeah
for those who came in late uh we uh
moved out of our house that we lived in
for over 20 years and we moved into a
house in the valley which I've talked
about here on the show I was like Hey
Valley neighbor welcome we're going to
barbecues we're going to I this going to
be great four months later we moved back
to our old house and now we're selling
the house in the valley it's up for sale
right now if you want to live in a house
I lived in for four months
kids um so we're back at uh the house
that we've been in uh forever and stuff
it was tough to leave behind and and
when we left they fixed it all up and we
were like this looks great and suddenly
we fell in love with it we were like in
the Wall Street Journal like when
they're like he's selling his [__]
house this is what it looks like and
[__] [__] and 9 days after it went on
sale like we were like take it take it
down and they're like why and we were
like we want to live in it again those
pictures look really nice and it was
furniture that wasn't ours and [__]
we'll pay above asking I know when we
mov back in we're like this looks
nothing like the photos um so we moved
back in a week of moving back we had the
same [__] moving company and they
were like you could do it again four
months from now I was like we might [__]
you we might my money we're very fickle
in our middle age um so they moved us in
over the course of 5 days four days I
was there for and on Thursday night I
went and got on a flight to go to New
Jersey uh to do a thing at SM Castle
Cinemas my movie theater um when I was
uh like 1 hour from my house uh my wife
uh stepped off of the one there's a
stair that goes up to the platform where
our bed is in an out it's not like it's
on a platform in the middle of a room
rotating or something like that it's
just in a on a a step up into an Al Cove
where the bed is uh I have slipped on it
many times and [__] and I got a bruised
ass for like 6 months at one point she
split her chin at one point uh this was
like the worst it's ever been she went
to turn the light off and then stepped
on the step which literally I just did
this evening as well half of my foot was
on the step and I was wearing a slipper
with grips and still it slipped off and
my wife was on the couch who lived
through this exact same experience
painfully and had like [__] you know
flashbacks to her moment and [__] like
that she fell and my wife has very
pronounced
hips
um they're like handlebars um I'm glad
you said it I had to
yeah um they she landed in such a way
that her top of her leg they call it the
hip but it's the top of the leg it is
the hip but it's really the top of the
leg top of the
leg shatter Ed into her pelvis and into
her groin shattered the top of her leg
her hip her hip shatter top of her hip
shattered but to me the hip was the
pelvis and then I learned something in
all this painfully on my wife's behalf
but I learned without the pain the hip
is just the top of the leg when it
connects to the pelvis that's what
creates the hip so body didn't teach you
this [__] like no the leg bone connected
to the thigh bone connected to the hip
bone connect I never followed that song
it was too
complicated but essentially what they
did to replace the hip is they replaced
the top of the leg so the ball that goes
to the top of the leg that goes into the
socket that's all titanium now so she
had you know it was like 26 hours after
she fell some people get hip surgery in
their 70s she's F 52 completely
unprepared like wasn't like oh maybe I
should get my hip done like it fell
shattered she was like I've had a child
so I know what [__] pain is I had no
idea this is like unbelievably bad and
[__] um so she came home for the last 6
weeks I've been like playing nursaid and
stuff like that uh the good news is she
6 weeks after like the accident and it
was bad like she was by herself in the
house except with the dogs uh the house
was locked double bolted from inside
when the paramedics came they came with
the fire department and [__] like that
uh she's like you can't get in even if I
give you the door code because it's
double bolted and I'm like well your
windows are open we'll send up the
cherry picker and they send up the
ladder with a fireman climbing up and
all of a sudden the two German Shepherds
we have are like this is the moment
we've been waiting for and they're like
Intruder and thean was like I can't go
near that
[__] so uh [__] Austin Harley's
boyfriend had to break in go open the
front door let them in six [__]
paramedics had to cut her clothes off I
was like what why' they cut your clothes
off she's like my leg wouldn't work at
all and [__] so in order to [__] get
me on the stretcher they had to take my
[__] gear off and [__] um six people
to get her downstairs she was in
absolute [__] misery and Agony and
[__] happy to report 6 weeks later I
just left this [__] walking
around no cane whatsoever she went from
a walker to a Wheeler to a cane nothing
so Orthopedics man I I don't know about
anything else two things like I've got
experience with right like I had a heart
attack so I know like cardiovascular
medicine is fantastic they saved my life
I probably should be dead um Orthopedics
I now have experienced with because of
her it's [__] nuts dude they like
repl she's got like a robot you know not
a robotic cuz they AI she's got she's
got some [__] we went on strike
against AI hips my friend that's right I
should tell her I was like we struck
against you you're part of the problem
um it's crazy man how fast you could
heal from that like I would it would
seem like something like oh my God
you're going to be off your feet for
like six months and there she was
walking around so I've been with her
most of the time but last week I got to
break away because it was my mother's
78th birthday oh so me and my mom uh me
and Harley went down to see my mom Jen
couldn't fly it uh we went down saw mom
hung out with Mom and mom wanted to go
to Disney World so we went to Disney
World and I rode two rides that I hadn't
ridden before that are fairly new one is
the the um uh Guardians of the Galaxy
Cosmic rewind do they have that in
Disneyland or is it just there do they
no I don't bam they have a Guardians of
the G thing here but it's not the
Guardians of the Galaxy thing here they
have is Tower of a drop yeah it's it's
just retheme Tower of ter it's fun and
it's cool but yeah this is a completely
different [__] ride it's like a
roller coaster a dark ride indoors but
with like tons of footage and new stuff
Glen Close opens the ride because it
takes place on xandar and all of the
Guardians of the Galaxy are there and
the the only one the I don't know if
Bradley Cooper did his voice for Rocket
everyone else was who they were [__] I
mean May was it like Dom deise like was
it like the least rocket voice ever it
was carrot head oddly enough it didn't
quite sound like him but the ride is
[__] nuts and it's quasi sequel to
like the second Guardians of the Galaxy
um worth worth the price of admission
that was very very cool and then I rode
the Tron ride which is pretty dope as
well it's like a roller coaster light
cycle and you ride like on your stomach
as if you're riding a light cycle and
stuff um when I got on a ride they were
like you got to take your hat off put it
in the there's a bin in the front and I
was like all right I took my hat off and
then once the ride took off I was [__]
that I'm a grown ass man and I put my
hat back on and [__] and I tightened it
one more Notch cuz I was like you know
oh yeah secure this will be [__] good
this [__] thing took off and I felt
that hat starting to go and I was like
No And so the whole ride I'm this it's
one of those [__] photos they
[Applause]
take cuz at a certain point I was like
oh [__] if my hat falls off it falls on
the track maybe somebody derails and it
[__] turns the ride off for an hour
you know and maybe somebody gets killed
as well yes they they call it the hat
trick but I was yes it could be the hat
trick so uh there was this moment like a
grown-up moment I never would out as a
child there's a 53y old man as this ride
is like whipping you around like 120 m
per hour and I'm holding on to my hat
for dear life I had this [__] thought
ran through my head I was like maybe
sometimes sometimes they know what
they're talking
about and I don't know who they is but
in this instance it was the park it was
like take your [__] hat off I was
like no well I did at first I was too I
wasn't [__] I was too chicken to say
no I was like I will and then once they
were gone I was like [__] you and put it
back on but then [__] once [__] was
going south I was like I should have
listened it was like a something out of
the Bible like one of the morality
details and
[__] nine people were killed by Kevin
Smith's I know cuz that's the thing it's
like they're like what caused the
accident like this black hat worn
backwards the brim of it just slicing
necks as a Guillotines to the air whose
hat could it be like he wrote his name
in it Kevin Smith I'm like
[__] um worth going on that
ride but don't wear your hat yeah and um
what else did I do I have a question
though fire away um
why do you still have that bed on a
stair it's an excellent [__] question
like you've all tripped on it multiple
times one person completely [__] up
one side of their body yes and you
almost tripped on it today yes you're
like keep it on that lift it's fine
because if we took the bed off of it
what would go up there it' be this weird
little Al Cove that like people like
don't go up there it's
haunted you know you know and the wife
won't let me do it when we got back from
the when she was getting out of the
hospital I was like I'm taking the bed
off that one step and putting it in the
middle of the room that way you don't
have to climb up and [__] like that and
she was like no she slept on the couch
for like five [__] weeks rather than
do that one step up to the bed or rather
than do the sensible thing let me take
the bed down below and she she got very
specific ideas about where things belong
in that house and you'd imagine she'd be
mad at the house cuz I sure would have
been if I was laying in the [__] HP
I'd be like [__] that cursed house back
to the Val totally that's what I but I
said to her now I was like how you feel
and she was like it's not the House's
fault but I was like if this had
happened in the valley I'd never hear
the end of it you moved me to the
[__] Valley it destroyed my hip but
she won't say a bad word about the house
I mean just like nope it's my fault and
I'll learn from this this is like some
it's like Sig freed and Roy right like
we got these Tigers we love these tigers
tigers are the best Roy gets eaten by a
tiger s Freed's like you know what I
still love these tigers
get rid of the [__] Tigers man I'm
going to run that byy when I get home
like Mark says you're like sick freed
and Roy the bed is your tiger and you
can't not be with a tiger it's like I
fell down that flight of steps should we
not put the bed upstairs no I like a
challenge you're you're a married man
sometimes you just can't fight City Hall
man sometimes sometimes it's best just
to be like to your world I'm just living
in I'm just a squirrel trying to get a
nut but the next time you fall on this
lot of steps just I'mma laugh with every
time you go down
no this is on you now I mean that's yeah
she won't see it that way no of course
not she loves that house and I do too
don't get me wrong like when I left and
part of the reason I went back is like I
missed it like we had very high ceilings
and stuff like that and we moved to a
house with like ceilings that were
normal size and I felt I felt like a
hobbit you know my other house I felt
small and then in the new house I felt
you felt big yeah yeah and I don't want
to feel big no I like feeling
small um anyway that's what I did and
then the rest of the time um let me see
we did a a pickup for our flick
something we couldn't shoot in Jersey
back when we shot it we had to wait till
we shot it out here um and that was a
lot of [__] fun because it involved
some green screen and [__] and space and
Flash Gordon it was space yeah it it was
fun it was It was kind of cool um so I
did that um you know I don't know like I
I guess that's it I've just been around
the house I've been working
on um not just finishing up the movie
but working on the next one I'm writing
I didn't think I would do it for a long
time but I I had an idea and I was like
you know what I'm going to [__]
follow this and see where it leads and
it's led to something I really [__]
enjoy um I'm right you know are you
supposed to say anything yeah I can't
it's not for anybody it's okay but and
it's not like surprising nobody's gonna
be like holy [__] I'm writing another
James Isom movie
um not surprising it's what I do I guess
but I honestly didn't think I'd do it
for like we had a plan to do like the
third Jane tombob movie when Jay's
daughter Logan was 18 cuz then she could
play Harley's daughter in the movie Jay
Harley played Jay's daughter in Jay and
Silent Bob reboot so Logan would play
Jay's granddaughter and we thought
that'd be [__] up the Multiverse of
men exactly um but you know Muse was
just like so I got to wait [__] 10
years to do another
movie um and you know I was like well I
guess you're right and so I started
thinking about this thing and started
writing it and I [__] absolutely love
it and it's I'm writing it in the way
that I wrote Red State um in as much as
not that it's going to be nearly as good
but anytime I know where the movie's
going that means the audience knows
where the movie's going and since it's a
James Allen Bob movie and I don't know
the 18th probably the audience knows
where a lot of it's going to go any time
I feel that way I just [__] turn the
tables and write something completely
different every time I know what the
punchline is I'm forcing myself to find
a different punchline undercut it and
stuff so I'm using it as an exercise to
kind of sharpen the comedic knives if
you will mhm um and I've been having a
[__] blast doing it so next year
2024 is the 30th anniversary of Jaye
Silent Bob um because it's also the 30th
anniversary of Clerks but I don't own
clerks I own Jay and Silent Bob so we'll
be celebrating the 30th anniversary of
Jay and Silent Bob with nice mentions to
Clerks of course um so it could be a
good time to shoot shoot the flick and
it's like this is the best thing I could
say about it it would work even if it
wasn't jayes s and Bob like it's just a
movie it's like a comedy movie and [__]
and I love what we just did with the 430
movie and it's an insanely sweet film um
and it's got some funny stuff in it but
this is definitely like more of what I
have done historically and whatnot so
I've been having a [__] blast doing
that um that's where I've been what you
been uh you been writing at all I've
been writing I've been writing like when
when the strike ended and Hollywood kind
of went back to work specifically when
the actor strike ended and everybody was
like great let's go make stuff let's
start buying stuff let's start doing
stuff a lot of projects that had been
kind of on pause for most of the Year
became unpaused right and so lots of
people began expecting things and asking
for things and so it's been a couple
months of hopefully delivering on that
stuff um I can't talk about any of it
because of course I can't I can't talk
about I went on a tour of Sideshow
collect cbles have you ever been out to
Sideshow yes yo that's where you want to
die and be buried right you guys it's so
great yeah like my I had lots of
favorite Parts all of it was like I need
a bigger house maybe I'll buy your house
in the valley just for all the toys that
I'm going to get from Sideshow I bet you
I can get you a real good deal it's real
sweet um and one of the things that I
that I did manage to get from them is
somewhere back here um that we're giving
away tonight as part of our Q&A prizes
as a as a a li SI show collectible Jammy
Jam that Andrew probably has buried
somewhere to your left he
said ah thank you B hey Bam F's back
everybody so I have B toid show mhm and
they took me to the like store where you
can get like a sweatshirt or a t-shirt
or a book did you get like something
special it all depends on who you go
with that's what that's what became
clear to me my favorite part though is
we walking around Sideshow and there's
like toys everywhere statues everywhere
all of it's cool and then there's like a
staircase going from one floor to
another floor and in the back is just
like a like a little bookshelf and like
nothing's lit up nothing's fancy it's
just like extra dolls and whatever and
in the back unlit like buried in Shadow
is the uh is the the kedon figure from
the Mandalorian the Gina corano figure
I was like did that ever I'm sure they
sold it they made it but like let this
be a warning to
you this is what happens when you run a
foul of Lucas film we bury you in the
corner you get moved to the back yeah I
was like H they should walk every new
actor through here and be like don't do
that here there be monsters um yeah that
place is pretty magnificent yeah
especially because they've got you know
[__] the sculptures that you can buy
and put on a table and then they have
life-size [__] where you're like and I
asked him I was like what's how what
sells more is it the statues that are
super cool or the life-size stuff like
lifesize stuff like by a factor of three
or four we sell more of these than we do
of the normal stuff I was like how who
who's buying stuff he's like book stores
Saudi
princes he's like we shipped 40
Stormtroopers to a mall opening in Abu
Dhabi I was like damn wow
and a Darth Vader and some uh fet and a
this he's like we have the it's like a
chest set of life-sized Imperial figures
in a mall in Abu
Dhabi it's oil
money I was going to say I feel poor yes
I was going to say I've said this I
don't even have one large [__] thing
I mean I got iron Bob but that's because
I made a [__] whole ass movie to get
it and [__] but like I don't have like a
huge Iron Man or something like that and
how many they got they got they we
bought 40 Storm
Troopers uh I have a uh hold on I'm
having an existential
crisis what has it all been for yeah I'm
like what am I spending my money on if I
don't have at least a big Iron Man and
now like my kid doesn't live there and
[__] and like my my wife's parents who
lived with us like for 20 years they
don't live there so there's so much room
in the house and I know I didn't make
that movie but I I think I would I think
I would like a giant Iron Man how how
much you got but I don't want to pay for
it so who did you go with I'll I'll I
I'll tell you a thing about a thing yeah
uh but I what I'm curious about is
exactly how much room you now have in
the house and if you might be willing to
accommodate a family of
four because I will get rid of my house
in the valley and move in with you and
it'll be like film Camp all day long
since the kid doesn't live there anymore
and and Jen's parents moved out like we
did have extra rooms and at one point I
was like you know like we could air be
and she's like shut the [__]
up she was like no we won't be doing
that and I was like why she's like cuz I
listen to a lot of crime
podcasts peltro does it though right
that's what I I literally said the same
thing I was like gwenneth paltro does it
and she was just like uhhuh gwth palro
does a lot of [__] you want to do what
she does all the time where's your
vagina candle and I was like fair enough
and then I walked away muttering where's
your vagina candle she didn't hear me so
it was cool yes was fine and I
said
[__] not even in a
dream over to you bman you've wanted to
say something for oh I was going to say
I have a um life-size figure that I
bought for myself on my 39th birthday
birthday is it a Star Wars thing it's uh
a Jessica Rabbit it is a life-sized jar
jar banks that that was in my dining
room I I know it's well no my question
is why no I'm saying why why you want go
back where you were why isn't it here uh
because people [__] with
it like it's that what it comes down to
you're like I don't want him touching my
jar jar yeah it's
mint it so it's been in our dining room
for 4 years yeah and Jen was finally
like can we can we get that out of the
dining room before Christmas and yeah
there it is Andrew put it up that's a
jar jar cake for our fourth birthday at
scum and villan and my life siiz jarar
in my dining room uh so wait your wife's
like get it out of here so I put it out
in my office office and uh and Joselyn
came out and was like where is jar jar
and was so upset because JN for those at
home who arey is his three-year-old and
so she she was pissed cuz it's been
there her whole life right and so I said
to Jen I was like the kids are real good
about you know [__] taking things
away I was like uh I was like I feel
like we've had dinner as a family of
four
for the last 3 years and now we're a
family of three with one member
ostracized to a dark office and Jen was
like I hate to admit it but yeah so it
went back into the room no it's still in
my office she didn't care that
much bring it here people it's Hollywood
people like people will anything that's
touchable that's why like every cool
thing we haveit I'm sorry is this was
this not an ironic gift to oneself like
nobody buys a jar jar going I literally
love it I I mean I did do a 2-hour
podcast on my jarar is the best
character in Star Wars is he really your
favorite it started off as ironically my
favorite but like as I went deeper and
deeper into it it he kind of became my
favorite and oh my God this is like' 88s
team comedy Can't Buy Me
Love you're like this is a [__] joke
and now you're like I do love him the
the easiest way to describe it is it's
like as a Star Wars
fan like when I loved Star Wars
everybody hated Star Wars and now
everybody loves Star Wars well they did
yeah for
pre25 and I was just like what's the
thing that I could do that just shows
how extreme my Star Wars fandom is is so
I just went deep into jar jar and like
the psychology of Jar Jar and the whole
thing and and and I yeah what started as
irony that show the world yeah just
became like my thing fing he look at
that well before you buy your next drink
know that a portion of it the proceeds
probably go buy some jar jar
[__] you just don't bring it here
because you don't want somebody to
accidentally [__] Jar Jar Binks in your
bar sounds lifesize right right
I mean than like you want to be let's be
honest too by process of elimination
this world of possibilities somebody has
[__] a jar jar statue and let's be
honest it's probably because they
drilled their own
hole and let's be honest it's probably
you what you doing in the workshop honey
nothing
wo I don't want to eat in the same room
with that thing that you
[__] get it in your office oh M I love
it anyway should we talk about a sponsor
for
this what a great time let give thanks
to those who uh give us uh look so we do
the show they're going to love this uh
tonight's episode is brought to you by
the good people at fume oh let me tell
you something man I do like uh I I legit
love the people of fume they sent me a
fume and they sent me
lavender scking a fume fume is not even
a smoking device it's like a how do they
describe it it's a sucking device no
smoke comes out of it but it's like
having a thing in your mouth suing
device you got to pay more for that yes
um it it's it's coming through now yeah
it's coming through now uh okay intro be
smart don't start kick the habit and put
it out before it puts you out all
phrases we've heard a thousand times yet
we still continue to do bad habits uh
person struggle any bad habit that's
hard can't be smoking or vaping to kick
the story uh should I not be reading the
instructions on especially not the
parenthetical stuff that's like do not
read this out say anything about this
our SP fume is on a mission to
accelerate Humanity's breakup from the
bad habits that consume far too many of
us fume is a natural diffusive device
there you go a natural diffusive device
that just rolls off the top it really
does that uses plants and Behavioral
Science to help you trade out your
negative habit for a positive one fume
is not a vape no it is a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits I wonder if you could
use this on a plane because it's not a
vape and it there's no electronic parts
I'd like to see you try and be right
next to you with my camera out it might
it might be worth a shot because it's
not like I've i' in order that you open
it up and you load in this like a stick
that's called a core core is that what
they call it but it's like a little
stick that goes inside and then you
close it and then you just breathe so
the Mint one is just like you're sucking
like you know [__] winter fresh gum
all the time inhale it and you're like
ah it's crisp but there's nothing comes
out no it's a diffusive advice instead
of PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemicals like a vape fume uses cores
infus with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon and lavender for delicious
natural flavors and you know I love
lavender hell yeah more than Prince uh
fumees new version 2 model is Snappy and
tactile with an adjustable airflow dial
and a magnetic end cap your fingers will
always tracks that's legit
true well done good P keep going thank
you your fingers will always have
something to do always uh talk about the
look feel and taste uh do you want to
talk about the look feel tast fantastic
honestly it's it it really is like um
the feel of the actual device is wood
and it's got metal pieces to it and
stuff but it's got the weight of you
know those of us who've had a habit or
you know sometimes people talk about
just wanting to have a thing in your
hands well this takes care of that and
then as you suck in it's Pleasant tastes
good and it smells nice and [__] um but
there is no smoke no Vapor or anything
like that I wonder if it could be used
on a plane it's like literally like
smoking a straw so it's like like a
candy
cigarette I think even that might have
more harmful [__] chemicals
and additives this is all natural and
stuff uh the easiest way to stop a bad
habit is to switch to a positive one and
fume is designed perfectly to do just
that it's fumees goal to make switching
easy and even enjoyable they have
thousands of five-star reviews from
people just like you who successfully
switched when other Solutions didn't
work I can see it yeah I can see them
having a lot of great yeah yes head to
Tri fume TR yfu m.com and use code
Fatman to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today Journey pack comes
with three unique flavors in the new
version 2 fume to help Kickstart your
positive habits that's what they sent me
the version two fume yeah it's clicky
clicky yeah uh that's TR f.com and use
code fat man to save an additional 10%
off on your order today and we thank the
good Folks at fume for sponsoring this
final episode of 2023 give it up for the
good Folks at fume we did
[Applause]
it uh can I uh sell some things too sure
before we get into the top 10 and the
news and q's and A's we got graphics uh
okay so uh I'll start with some smart
Castle stuff kids uh I've been away from
Smart castle since
November uh third we had an event there
and then that's when Jen shatter her hip
and so I haven't been able to go back
for anything so we've got four events
coming up in January if you're on the
East Coast um first up is uh SM aution
which is uh something we do before every
show that I'm at at smle where we
auction off props and [__] like that and
signed things from people who've been
there um posters and stuff like Jason
Lee's been there and stuff Joey Adams so
they signed stuff we auction that off uh
we're doing a whole [__] show cuz
people sometimes the auction that we do
before the movie you've been there for
for a fat man beyond sometimes goes like
[__] the longest one was 3 hours long
and the audience is like when are we
watching the movie it's like after this
is done so a lot of people like why
don't you do your own [__] auction
show I like I will so the whole show is
nothing but [__] auction and stuff
that's happening on
June 6th January January January 6 thank
you I knew something was wrong about
that you heard it in my voice I'm like
the other June 6th yes wait you're
having it on January
6th oh no happy anniversary everybody I
guess come storm the castle and buy my
storm the SM castle that's right buy my
SM Castle Insurrection um well it's not
a holiday we got to keep sacred or
anything and and the kind of thing we
want to like [__] put behind us and
not celebrating that way I'm pretty sure
the Catholic Church celebrates like when
did Jesus die well January 6 is actually
a Catholic holiday it's Epiphany little
Christmas it's called how weird that I
just [__] pulled that from my
Catholic training
that's like when [__] Batman loses
his mind and becomes the Batman of Zur
and Ron [__] just like the programming
he's like if I'm ever taking over a
[__] program kicks in where I can be
Batman even if I [__] have lost my
mind that's what the Catholics did to me
they did so even though I haven't been
in [__] church for [__] years I
was able to pull that [__] just like
that that's some RZ all ghoul [__] that
really is trust your training Master
Bruce truly I might be able to do all
the Stations of the Cross from memory
go nope oh
can't [__] remember a one I know it
doesn't work out well for Jesus yeah
Domin still be all right kind of like
the Titanic um all right so January 6th
is no longer going to be remembered for
that stuff it's going to be remembered
as the day of Smokin also the day of the
15th anniversary screening of Zach andir
Make a Porno um that screening is nearly
almost sold out already kids those
tickets are on sale right now at SM
Castle cinemas.com then I come back 2
weeks later
uh to do two uh things uh and one is the
second time we've done it last year we
did an event called clerks open all
night where you know you come at 10:00
at night we lock you in you sleep at the
theater uh you spend the night with me
and we watch all the clerk's movies the
entire Clerk's Saga and [__] pedophile's
dream why it's just locky in the theater
buddy you can't leave we're all [__]
grown-ups there's no children there you
you're the only one brings a child to a
bar he's of
majority um yes it's not a pedophile
thing at all dude [__] the internet
sh I'm selling [__] here man they get
[__] weird um it's just us sitting
around watching clerks and we had a
great time doing it uh last year uh
we're doing it again so Clerk's open on
night two happens on Janu January 20th
uh that is also half sold out at this
point so get your tickets fast and then
I think the day after that we're doing
Batman
returns showing Batman Returns uh they
wouldn't let us show it before the flash
came out now they're like you can show
it whatever you want yeah didn't you
want to show Batman go ahead show the
can you show the flash as well all the
Batman um always a good time to be had
at SM Castle kids uh there you got that
clip Andrew Russo Brothers
clip
russos yes all right so this is like the
last time I was this SM Castle we did
this thing uh uh on November 3rd where
the Russo Brothers came to smack castle
and I got to interview him we shot the
whole thing uh but uh this is a little
piece that's kind of very relevant to
our crowd I guess remember you know the
the Kur fuffle about the do office yeah
um he they address it and uh I pulled
this clip to show here uh in a world
where Arrested Development can trace his
Origins back to man bites dog
um you guys have you're wearing the same
very schooled in your subject what a
horrible fashion watch a lot of [__]
going up I mean we were just Fanatics I
mean I watch you know it was
like in there too and so is lost in
space and what they're saying is I would
imag many amongst your influences
many do you hear that in who who doesn't
are are we not
everybody for the record everybody loves
Barton SC go back one of the reasons in
a world where Arrested Development can
trace his Origins
back
hey well that went
great doesn't that make you want to go
to smog castle of course it does uh we
ready to try again Andrew to be fair it
was playing the audio on the stream just
not in the room figed but everyone in
the room it was such an awkward sit for
a minute they were just looking at us we
had no answers for them um all right
Andrew take it away show them man bites
dog um you guys have you're very
schooled in your subject matter um yeah
we watched a lot of [__] growing up I
mean we were just Fanatics I mean I W
you know it was like Doby Gillis is in
there too and so is lost in space and
you
know Island many amongst your influences
many Scorsese films as well me many
scors
films um who who doesn't every SC yes
everybody for the record everybody loves
barttin cres yes everybody does he's one
of the reasons one of the biggest
reasons that we're sitting up here right
is the the influence of his movies and
you know it's interesting because uh uh
you know my daughter runs my social
media account the way his daughter runs
his social media account and we saw this
cute video he did with his dog and we
happen to have an identical dog
both snowers yeah they're both SCH
snowers and I thought this is hilarious
this could be really cute and his video
is him his his video is him talking to
his dog he's coaching it through you
know like he's train like it's going to
do a part for him and his dog's name is
his dog's name is
Oscar uh and my daughter was like that's
funny she was like what if our dog's
name was box office and I went oh that's
funny that's
cute uh and then you know we posted it
did on Tik Tok like a week we do a bunch
of Tik Tok videos together it's like how
I stay connected to my daughter um you
know she has all these funny ideas and
we're trying all this [__] all the time
and we posted it and then like people
discovered it like a week after we
posted it so you post it you're like
that was fun did something with the kids
life is good yeah and then uh you know I
think people conflated the timing of
when they discovered it with this movie
which was not the intention this was
just like a broad appeal joke you know
it's like he's got a funny dog named
Oscar I've got a little schneer named
box office and you know [__] storm
ensues yeah it wasn't I I mean when I
saw it I wasn't like oh he got him he
[__] sure got him I was like oh
that's adorable and [__] the internet on
the other hand had different ideas they
did I got internetted
yes they internetted all over your face
NE and
chest this is brought to you by that
kevinsmith club.com that's right man if
you can't get enough of the sound of my
voice
that they're already hearing too much of
me uh I'll tell you what as Mark pointed
out I'm dressed the exact
same it's all right um come on out to SM
Castle Cinemas kids tickets available
right now at SM Castle cinemas.com uh
can you throw the comic book covers
Andrew uh quick stops volume two number
one came out this week cool cool and uh
three different covers uh kids that one
by Ahmed that one by chin and then that
one by our very own dark Nate Nate
Gonzalez did that cover looks like the
Watchman uh this is my Movie secret
origin story the first round of quick
stops was all issues about the
characters various characters from The
Vi Universe uh this time around it's
just the secret origin story of movie
The Golden CF and it it is perhaps the
most salacious thing I've ever written
in my life that's saying something yeah
truly it should of course you know since
is about a kid's cow be very simple and
innocent but it's anything but uh and
and Ahmed did such a great job drawing
it so that is available right now at
your local comic shop or Jane sbob
secret stash which is celebrating coming
up on its 27th year in business as a
brick
and uh thank you they're on the other
side of the country so they can't hear
you but I appreciate it um and I think
that's all I got man
um is Shannon
here jump on let's talk to Shannon real
quick uh Andrew throw up a p picture of
the
snakes
sneakers yeah jump over to they can't
see you unless I go over there see those
sneakers so I got a bunch of custom vans
um and I got I started doing this
started wearing them uh because this a
lovely girl came up to me after I did a
thing at a complex store in the valley
and uh after the show she said your
shoes are terrible wear these and she
gave me a pair of movies
Vans uh her name on Instagram is one
crafty punk as in the number one uh but
we know her Shannon give it up for Shan
and everybody say
[Applause]
hi put the put the camera on her Andrew
on Shannon I
know there you go there's Shannon
everybody at home thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
um everyone every time I wear these
sneakers or any and I've got about eight
pair that Channon did um people are
always like o [__] where'd you get them
and I try to explain and stuff and and
that's when they're like wait I got to
[__] go find this person on Instagram
you paint sneakers yes um how long you
been doing it probably 10 12 years and
from scratch no pattern sometimes I'll
give myself like a guide or a little bit
of a pattern or kind of like a stencil
but right mostly yeah I sketch out all
my ideas like on procreate and kind of
piece together my layout and how I want
to do it and then what do you got in
that Van's box what's in the box a new
PA yeah yeah please going Poo's head
no oh oh does the other one say rats oh
all the other one says
R hold that [__] up JC put that put that
up in that camera man oh that's
fresh there you go look at this [__]
kids so those ones I knew you weren't
expecting and had not requested but he's
coming there you go look at that
[__]
gorgeous how long it take you to do a
long time I try not to keep track
because I'll just make my brain um
several hours hands down beautiful work
i' I again I've got this will be that'll
are those for me yes that's the ninth
[__] pair I got thank you so much
love wearing them when I podcast I wear
them all the time here I don't wear
because nobody sees my feet behind the
bar uh so I wear the hocas you don't
wear them from me you've see them when
you go to SM Castle when I'm at SM
Castle back do people see feet all the
time and I wear them all the time um I
would like to uh
purchase a pair of custom vans for Mr
Bernard in here for me what would you
put on a pair of sneakers Merry
Christmas by the way thank you uh it
feels like it should be fat man you
could you could totally take the F be
beond or you could do a door in the
distance bro I I could yeah or you could
do your what's the mace window series
called you could do mace you Star Wars
I'm not I'm not going to I'm not to
custom do somebody else's [__] that
feels weird bu if if Disney heard you be
like I don't want to buy Star Wars [__]
like cut it down be like we're in
trouble no I think I think fat man yeah
that's the one so you'll have a pair of
fat men Beyond sneakers before I
will yes I
will and I will be the bell of the ball
sir fair enough gift is a gift um we
will make it happen yes you can make
that happen we'll shoot some sketches
around and you can finalize and let me
know if uh anybody out there wants to
hire you we run the potential of having
you work for the next three years
straight by unleashing this information
to for um where can they find you on
Instagram at one crafty Punk and is that
where you that's the best way to the
best place to do it do you Etsy as well
I tried but so Instagram is way to go
flooded and they take too much money and
I take too long a paint so uh kids I I
can't say enough good things about the
skips if you're a Vans person some
people like wearing Vans I love Vans um
I can do other shoes you guys I can do
Nikes I just the prep work on Nike and
any leather is a lot more than these I
can just yeah I love I can do purses
wallets do you really do all that [__]
as
well I'm a shoe junkie I love my Vans so
it was just like the merging of the two
together makes sense to me and it's just
what I love done and done kids at home
go check out on Instagram one crafty
Punk c r f t y p and K give it up for
shann and K thank you Shan that's
awesome I would put those on back here
but [__] it's so sticky back
here I'll I'll grab yeah I'll take I'm
put them right on the [__] bar so
everybody could see him on the put them
on the
glass look at that [__] give me that
front sh you look at that
[__] this [__] symmetry get it right
in the middle kuri syet there you go
it's been bugging me I'm leaning toward
you all night like I'm scared I got to
learn to stay over here cuz look that's
a better shot like you're scared yeah
like this is look at that framing it's
terrible look at all that Dead Space
it's like but over here this makes more
sense but I like being near you to be
honest I feel safer here amongst all
these [__] people if somebody makes a
jump you got my
back from over here Anything could
happen and [__] be seconds before you
could react um okay what should do now
uh we have news we have uh my best of
2023 um where do you want to go first
let's leave it up to the kids where do
you guys want to go news or best
of well that was a mistake how about
this uh clap for
news Okay clap for best
of ladies and gentlemen Mr Mark Bernard
uh always puts together a list and says
hey I'm putting together a list will you
do it and I'm like all right and then I
never do um but thankfully most of the
stuff on his list I get to comment on
however because I've also seen however
there are things that Mark has put onto
his list in the past which took me a
little while to catch up to Case in
point few months ago I [__] wrote
Mark out of the blue to be like I just
finally watched train to
buan didn't you talk about that N9 years
ago you know he was like yeah yeah I was
like it's [__] amazing he's like I
told you I told everybody he really did
um so it's a list uh that let you look
back at the year and go oh [__] I
remember that with some titles that will
make you go I didn't even hear about
that [__] so without further Ado summing
up are you calling it The Best of 2023
I'm I'm calling it The Best of 2023 with
some caveats there you go man give it up
for Mr Mark Bernard and ladies and
[Applause]
gentlemen uh the the caveats are namely
uh for television there's no returning
shows so we are not going to talk about
the bear as much as I love the bear
we're not going to talk about which by
the way I finally caught up with and
absolutely [__] he's right two years
late he's absolutely right two years ago
he said you should watch the bear I was
like I will and I did two years later um
when the rest of the world did it's
fantastic if you haven't seen it it's
glorious soing on telev Fargo we won't
talk about For All Mankind which I love
and if you're not watching you 100%
should Fargo you this season's Fargo
this season's Fargo [__] John Ham
wearing nipple rings hell yeah I can't
stop jerking off to that show I'll be
honest with you I don't know what's
going on cuz the moment they show that
I'm
like did you see how violently that
happened I know you punished your John H
I was I was also going this punched on
John
Ham um back to you uh what we do in the
shadows you want to talk about Harley
Quinn we won't talk about despite the
fact that all of them had great Seasons
yes uh this is the new stuff so okay
fair enough everyone got that I was
going to re explain it but I think he
did a great job and also because a movie
isn't on this list doesn't mean that I
or isn't on the list doesn't mean that I
hated it there's just some [__] that I
haven't seen fair enough like I still
haven't seen killers of flower Moon yet
I haven't seen past lives I haven't seen
like there's a raft of Oscar movies that
are still just beginning to come down
the pike that haven't se I haven't seen
Wonka yet so we're not talking about
that right um we do have some wona stuff
to give away later on thanks to our good
friend Deacon when we do our uh the Q&A
part we are 4dx ing Wonka yeah are they
blasting candy up your ass yes you sit
in the chair and they just fill you full
of [__] Everlasting Gob
Stoppers yeah no thank you um so yes
that is not in any way an indictment of
the things we're not talking about fair
enough so many disclaimers Just Launch
all right honorable mentions okay stuff
that did not crack the top 10 fair
enough Monarch Legacy of monsters you
watched it and dig it I'm caught up
Russell and his kid Wyatt and uh and
Godzilla not sure if you're familiar
with Godzilla how often does does
Godzilla make an appearance per episode
is there a monster per episode uh
there's a God you get Godzilla once
every like three episodes do you get
anybody else uh yeah other monsters yeah
but not like like there's no gamra
there's no gidra there's no Mothra you
get like then there's no Kev um I uh
I've made the mistake of saying on the
show in the past that like why do they
ever sh show the human story just show
me monsters beating each other up and I
was called like a heathen online they're
like don't you [__] understand the
human story is what it's all about
nobody wants to watch just monsters
fighting I
disagree um so I will say I know the
human part is important is this just the
human part over and over again uh it's
it it's a bit of a it's the mystery it
is the human part to a certain degree
but it is not quite the the there's
another title we'll talk about later on
which is very much the human part and
it's phenomenal but we'll get there okay
we'll get there but this is more like
what if the X Files also was about
Godzilla and like that's also kind of
cool does it passed the Godzilla Beckel
test in as much as is there ever a
conversation where people aren't talking
about Godzilla because let's be honest
if Godzilla existed that's all we'd
[__] talk about uh there Trump's not
Godzilla we all talk about it so imagine
if something that [__] huge could
knock buildings over had [__] Atomic
breath and [__] like that there wouldn't
be like there would be no scenes in that
show where people are like how you doing
really people would be like oh my God is
it amazing we haven't been killed by
Godzilla yet uh I'll say like three qus
of all the conversations are about
Godzilla yes and then there's a sort of
relationship that's at the center of it
about these two kids who disc
that their father was leading two
separate lives including with two
separate women who are each of their
mothers and he was also an agent of
Monarch which seems to be the
overarching organization that's
investigating not hearing any Godzilla
and any of this sounds like human
problems I got those of my own I just
want to see giant things beating the
[__] out of each other it's called
escapism no I understand it's important
you like it it's got honorable mention
honorable mention watch when I watch it
3 years from now i' be like Mark have
you ever seen Monarch it's worth an
honorable mention
it's just the human part yeah
uh Beckham the Netflix documentary about
David Beckham you did give that High
Praise when we talked a few weeks back
it's pretty extraordinary especially
because if you're a kid who spent any
time at all in the 80s or 90s and you
will remember this person and whether or
not you remember him as a soccer player
football player uh as a sort of fashion
model as just a famous person at the
height of Fame um the way they sort of
dig into his life and excavate all of
the drama underneath it and examine what
Fame actually meant in a place where you
couldn't walk around and not be David
Beckham like and all of the attention
that that gave like he had to flee
countries because there was too much
heat on him and so it's it's an
interesting examination into both Sport
and the the abject Insanity of being
famous doesn't matter if you know
anything thing about I could care less
to a certain degree about football other
than the Ted lasso of football right um
but but it it it invests you in it in a
way that happens quickly and effectively
multi episodes or like one two hour four
episodes [__] four one hours why does
everything have to be so [__] long
man like they put up what did I watch
like [__] oh I watched Leave the
World Behind MH and when I looked at the
running time I was like 2 hours and 20
minutes what the [__] but then at the
end I was like it's
over it can't be over keep it going and
[__] he kept that [__] gripping for two
hours and 23 minutes so that's a bad
example but everything is a series man
like why why can't they just tell the
story in two [__] hours I don't know
man but it's real good all right fair
enough all right um the
Marvels yes loved it watched it this
that was this year that was that was
like three weeks ago oh the Marvels I
thought you meant M Marvel yeah Marvels
that was this
year uh yeah like it's it is not the
best Marvel Marvel movie ever it is
maybe in the top half of them but it it
100% does what you want a movie to do it
gets in it gets out it makes you laugh
it makes you feel a thing about a thing
like it's and the cast is phenomenal
like I don't know what more you wanted
from a movie like this because for me it
gave me everything I was looking for it
is uh you know it's been the whipping
boy or girl in this case for the last
few months but I think Aquaman's about
to take be like hold my beer Glo GL
yeah I they they didn't do a premiere
for Aquaman at all and they're not
letting anybody they're embargoing the
reviews until the actual day comes out
never really a good sign and I read one
box office projection report that said
it may not open as well as Blue Beetle
did oh damn that's a sequel to a billion
dooll grossing movie like what the [__]
happened man what happened this year is
like we entered the upside down nobody
gives a [__] about Marvel or star Star
Wars anymore you and I we're
[__] this show [__] you know we got
to start talking about politics or
something man cuz nobody cares about
[__] Star Wars and Marvel anymore it
can't be [__] I'm getting
shoes good point we got to stay alive
for one more season I got to get the
shoes um yeah man the Marvels God that
did just happen didn't it but worth
worth the honorable mention you're
absolutely right indeed um American
fiction
some of the
people the makers of American fiction
ladies and gentlemen indeed uh they're
they're a bit wher American fiction is a
movie written and directed by cord
Jefferson who if you don't know the name
he's the guy who wrote The Black and
White episode of Watchmen Nostalgia and
won an Emmy for it okay um this is his
writing directorial debut starring
Jeffrey Wright and Sterling K Brown and
uh and who else is in it Leslie
hams um Leslie hams but it's it's an
adaptation about a novel Jeffrey Wright
is playing an author um who is
struggling with his identity as a as a
sort of black author in modern America
who decides that rather than write
scholarly Works about you know
characters having their own existential
crisis he's going to write the shittiest
novel he possibly can the most
stereotypically black thing that anybody
has ever written and that becomes the
book that everybody wants to buy that
becomes the book that becomes a runaway
bestseller and so it's all about sort of
him synthesizing whatever version of
himself can deal with being a sellout
but also does become a commentary on the
industry that he's selling out to [__]
um what's the title American fiction I
mean doesn't really give you a hint of
what's to come like you you just did a
better job of selling it than the title
did I mean it's can that be the title
everything you just said everything I
just said it's it's all of that things
um but it's it's a really it's a really
strong debut from a person who never
directed before never wrote a feature
before um the performances are great
Jeffrey Wright can do no wrong Sterling
K Brown can do no wrong um and it's like
an hour and 45 minutes I'm in see um
what is is it streaming someplace um no
it's in theaters now it just opened New
York and LA in Atlanta and it's going to
go wide in a couple of weeks but every
Festival that's gone to it's won I think
it won the audience prize at Toronto
it's won the audience prize at at like I
don't know Santa Barbara New York Tiff
like everywhere it's gone it's performed
really well American fiction kids I'm in
it's been glob and Globe nominated for
best picture and Jeffrey right it's
going to be one of those movies we're
going to talk about for a while Oscar
screeners Oscar screen probably um but
see everything in a theater if you
possibly can preferably it's my castle
Cinemas yes see how I'm still like
gravitating toward Mark I'm so scared
over there I got I got I got my like
haunted in that corner of the bar I got
my a little box here like I can just
move and you're like I want to in but
see over here feels weird I no but if
you look up at the camera it's like
there's a natural div divis dividing
spot between it is and if I'm over here
like it's growing out of my head it's a
terrible [__] shot I know I'm the guy
that shot clerk so I shouldn't talk but
like [__] all I have to do is this
and that looks better but it just feels
so foreign cuz I just want to be
like hey
uh finally um this is still honorable
mentions yes one last honorable mention
Jesus listen dude we're blazing just
[__] make a list of 15 [__] oh go
ahead I'm in American fiction damn uh
Teenage mut ninja turtles mutant Mayhem
the the Seth one the Seth one so much
fun good like it it it doesn't exist
without the spiderverse movies I think
that they were sort of unlocked by what
you could get away with thanks to to
that stuff but again it's like 90
minutes long the kids are great the
action is super fun it looks like art it
looks like somebody who could draw drew
a movie with crowns and I'm kind of here
for it it's is that now streamable
everywhere yeah like I think it's hit
its home video phase so it's it's at
home all right there's your honorable
mentions kids
indeed now number 10 here we go here we
go here's the meat and potatoes number
10 Guardian of the Galaxy part three
excellent wonderful time at the movies
uh you know I'm it's not saying much but
I cried U but who didn't at this [__]
movie man you had to be like a [__]
robot there's some scenes like
particularly with rocket and his friends
which were [__] heartbreaking which
is insane considering they were all CG
characters and not even like you know
cute they were all altered [__] in
horrible ways and [__] and still their
perform performances the performances of
the actors who played the vo of the
characters shine through made those
performances so very human I think that
it's the best it's the best performance
Bradley Cooper's ever given now I
haven't seen Maestro
yet so I don't know but like up until
then not as controversial either no I
mean he all of it fake nose on Guardians
all of it's fake everything fake
everything um but it's the best he's
ever been and that part of the story is
so fantastically well [__] movie yeah
rest on his shoulders thank God it
wasn't like let's do Groot yes no uh
number nine Poker Face on peacock oh wow
that was mentioning it a while back that
was like January and it stayed on the
list it stayed on the list because
there's there's something so wonderful
and I think we're beginning to remember
the joys of an episodic TV show where
it's like every episode is a new story
like there's a to long mythology as
opposed to the like serialized We are
following Walter White for Five Seasons
which is great but like you can just
jump in on the show any time you wanted
to and have an experience that's
complete and there's something kind of
wonderful about that Natasha Leon is
great Ryan Johnson directed like half
the episodes and they're great this his
show right didn't he create it he
created it with Natasha Leon they were
like we want to make Columbo yeah it's
like there should be more Columbo what
what did Natasha Leon do to
you
Bo Bo was that a boo
Ryan Ryan you don't like Ryan Johnson
all
right I he loves
you um but yeah no I love that show so
much fun it's on peacock still streaming
go watch it that was number nine that's
number nine here we go number eight kids
Leave the World
Behind what I just talked about before
yeah that jumped into your top 10 that
cracked into the top 10 like last week
wasn't it is made by Sam es samile did
Mr Robot Mr Robot and he did another
thing with Julie Roberts as well um he
did a there was a podcast that that he
adapted into live action the name of
which escapes me but it was very much
homecoming homecoming yes right well
done um but yeah Leave the World Behind
um it's on Netflix now it's their number
one movie on the on the service at the
moment right and it's about um a family
that's um Julia Roberts Ethan Hawk their
two kids who rent an Airbnb in like Posh
Long Island somewhere in like Sag Harbor
where the North Shore where the rich
people go um and then things start to go
weird um phones stop working there's
blackouts they can't get signal the TV
goes out there's no internet and there's
a knock at the door and it's Mersa Ali
and his daughter um played by one named
MAA I think you pronounce her name who
said that it's their house they it it
belongs to them he's wear of tux and it
then sort of launches into this this
story that is both about a very real
apocalypse that's very tangible there's
no aliens there's no outbreaks there's
no nothing it's just like what if
everything we rely on stops working and
it's also this very kind of cogent
satire about um white fear of black
wealth and black power like Julie
Roberts does not trust Maha Ali no
matter what he says no matter how many
times he proves this is his house no
matter how many times he's like okay you
guys can stay that's fine but like it's
my house you can't tell me I can't be in
my house and they're both trying to
navigate what seems to be the end of the
world yeah um so it's it's operating
like this this 2hour long Twilight Zone
episode that's incredibly tense and
Incredibly well performed that's that's
what he does insanely well is ratchet up
the tension and keeps it ratcheted the
the score helps the the this feeling of
[__] dread just keeps you glued to
move like I said before before when I
saw the running time over two hours I
was like come on but in it you don't
feel it and the whole time you're just
moving closer and closer to the TV and
like what is it what's going on like I
can't tell you how many times I turned
to my wife and I was like what is
happening you know and she's like I
don't know I'm watching it too I was
like what's with the [__] deer
like it's it's a pretty [__] in
involving watch now it's you know some
people I've seen online who were like I
don't like the ending I I'm shocked
that they went with the ending they went
with but not shocked you know mad I'm
just like most people like things neat
and Pat at the end yeah they found a way
to make it triumphant without at all
ending the story yeah without [__]
selling out on what they'd done before
cuz with movies like this at a certain
point you ratchet it up to a place where
it's like all right either this has got
to be a dream or [__] like credits
and it's like the day day after you know
[__] just something horrible and you
got to deal with it and [__] and uh they
they went toward the [__] latter path
but there's an oddly satisfying note
human note in the middle of it yeah it
is worth a watch uh really worth a watch
if you got Netflix and mostly everybody
does um it reminded me of Miracle Mile
okay remember Miracle Mile same [__]
like Miracle Mile is uh I would argue a
little lighter like I don't think it's
intentional like 80s and everything was
lighter totally uh but it's very it's
got that Tangerine Dream score and stuff
like that but Miracle Mile is a meat
cute shot out here at Miracle Mile um
where that Diner used to be now it's
gone they're building something there
and [__] but um some gu going to meet a
girl he met meet cute Matthew Modine no
it's uh Anthony Edwards the other
Matthew Modine
yes and and the girl is what's her name
she was in um Mary Elizabeth master
anonio no but what a great guest she was
in um St Emo's fire but she yes
excellent [__] pull um so they meet
cute in the park and they're like let's
go on a date we're going to meet at this
Diner at like 9:00 and he shows up and
as he's walking in the pay phone outside
rings and then he just [__] stops and
answers it and it's some guy going like
oh my God they did it they [__]
launched where's my dad it was Dad there
and he's like what are you talking about
he's like who is this and he's like you
just called the pay phone he's go I'm
trying to reach my dad I'm going a silo
they just launched at us we're just
launching back at them and then he's
like no no sir no and you hear gunshot
and the line go dead and [__] Anthony
Edwards walks into the diner and tells
the story and people in the diner some
people are like that's [__] stupid
and don't believe that and then there's
one person who I think is the C Denise
Crosby um who was on Star Trek yes she
uh has like an early [__] brick ass
cell phone where she's like I know
somebody in the Rand Corporation she
called calls up and she's like it's real
and the whole like these people in the
diner know that nuclear weapons are on
their way to the United States and the
rest of the city does it and slowly
finds out and this movie was shot in 19
I want to say ' 86 for a budget of like
1 million there's a shot in this movie
that pre-exists CG it's a crane shot
where they [__] open up on what is
the Wilshire and it is crowded with cars
as as far as the I can see it is a a
feat like and a half for any AD to have
pulled this off like with no money
especially but it's a harrowing shot of
like cars something that's similar that
we see in in um Leave the World Behind
cars just packed and there's nowhere to
go people running on top of cars uh that
movie escalates further and further to
the place where you're like it can't be
where it's going there's the picture
right there um and then it goes into a
third act which is unbelievably [__]
dark for a movie that started as a meat
Cube P.S they do meet like they do wind
up together but under the word they die
everybody [__] dies it is a harrowing
[__] film and this reminded me of
that like as I'm watching I was like he
must have seen [__] miracle M it's
not like he copied it but it's the same
sense of like holy [__] it's all coming
to an end and this is what would really
happen it's really worth watching even
if at the end you're like oh man it I'm
telling you you'd be lying if you're
like it didn't make me feel tense
throughout it it something in it will
[__] connect with you and make you go
that's [__] up the deer alone seemed
to be capturing people's imagination it
does um it doesn't make any sense but it
also doesn't matter doesn't matter uh
number seven Scott Pilgrim takes
off the cartoon the cartoon um I've I've
read all of the Scott Pilgrim's books I
watched the Scott pilg movie and I
thought to myself why are we doing this
again um and then I saw it and it 100%
earns Eight Episodes of we're doing this
again because everything that you think
you going to get it makes as you say
about writing the next day in Sal B
movie wherever you thought they're going
to make a left they make a right
wherever you thought they were going to
do a thing that you remembered or
recognized like oh I know where this is
going you 100% don't know where this is
going um it reminds me a little bit of
the reception to let's say somebody made
a master of Universe show that people
expected a thing and then didn't get the
thing
what's that like so weird um and so by
the way Masters the universe Revolution
coming in
2024 yeah wo sh don't don't I don't want
the internet getting mad at me again um
let him see hordak then they'll be fine
but I think people like came to this
expecting a Scott Pilgrim story and
discovered that it was a Ramona Flowers
show um and it's great for it it's
amazing it's it's so there's a device
that happens in early on that allows at
the end of the first episode you're like
what it makes a left instead of a right
and suddenly you're in completely
Uncharted Territory and it earns every
one of those episodes how many episodes
I think it's eight or is it 10 it's
eight eight and I've seen him say like
we're not doing it again he's like we
emptied the tank put everything we
wanted to put into this we didn't know
if we'd get another season now it feels
like why do another season like if an
idea occurs to us maybe three or four
years from now we'll think about it but
for now Scott Pilgrim took off and we're
done uh so that's number seven number
six is
Heimer um did anybody see the bomb
movie only a billion dollars worth of
people saw the bomb movie so I'm
assuming you guys did um it is it is not
what you think it is it is the rare
movie it's a bit like Titanic in which
you know what's going to happen you know
that like oh the bomb works so like the
tension of what normally would be this
movie of are they going to get it wrong
is the formula not going to work is
everybody going to die like no you know
it works and you know nobody's going to
die except for lots and lots of people
that the movie seems Inc concerned with
kind of at all which is my biggest knock
against it is it does not in any way
contend with the reality of dropping a
bomb on millions of people Oppenheimer
seems to have a bad couple of months is
is the ramification for that but it is
phenomenal film making it's incredibly
expertly done it feels like a thriller
even though it has no thrills for the
middle section of it and to your point
Robert Downey Jr will win an Oscar he's
like I and look especially in this room
most of us are in the bag for Robert
Downey Jr anyway the thanks to you know
the strong Tony Stark Iron Man work over
the last decade
plus but I'm not saying we forgot you
know he's just been doing so one thing
for so long and he had Sherlock in there
and a couple other movies and [__] but
there's a reason like there's a reason
he works so well as Tony Stark and it's
not because it's like oh he's kind kind
of like Tony Stark in real life he's
just an amazing actor and just because
he played that role so many times you
know you end to be like oh well how hard
can it be and yet he made it engaging
each and every [__] time yes we bring
our affection to the character and and
the history of how he's played the
character but every time he went up he
had to give something new and he did and
that's because he's a fantastic [__]
actor and always has been MH so I'm not
going to say like I forgot I've love him
for years particularly as Tony Stark but
when he was doing all the press for this
movie and going like this is my third
act or whatever I'm like third act like
how many act come on man nine acts yeah
you've had all the acts like share some
and [__] and then when I saw the movie I
was like God damn it he's right like he
could he could totally go on and never
[__] talk about Iron Man ever again
um and this this movie absolutely proves
that if he doesn't win an Oscar there's
no [__] Justice I mean there is no
justice but [__] you're right godamn it
for a second I thought there was yeah
but the reason why people went Oscars is
like did you do good work great that's
awesome but what's the narrative around
you this particular season yeah like jam
Lee Curtis won an Oscar last year
because hey she was very good and
everything everywhere all at once but
she was also Jam Lee Curtis who started
beloved for years beloved for years
started in horror like made her way
through like was a sex pot was it this
was it that you know a nepple baby one
of the OG nepple babies you know and
owned it and lived up to it like The
Narrative of her finding a way this late
in her career to do the thing that
everybody loved despite having loved her
for decades right that's why she won and
so RDJ in the ninth Act of his career
after like you know less than zero and
Weird Science and chaplain and jail for
three years and Kiss Kiss Bang Bang and
Iron Man and Tony all of that story is
the now he's ready to receive the
flowers that were due him decades ago
that he wasn't ready for yeah and now
here he is and so that's why he wins not
because he's better although he is but
it's because we can wrap our arms around
that story and celebrate it because he's
broken like the rest of us and that's
what the Oscars are very very good at is
funny The Narrative and paying off that
narrative um I hope I hope you're right
I mean honestly like I for everything
I've seen this year that was the
performance that stuck with me the most
in as much as I'm like wow like I I
thought I knew all of his colors I
thought I knew everything he was capable
of and here he is in his third act
showing us something that I'm like I'm
I'm still here I'm very interested look
at you doing what you did when I was a
kid and I would see you and [__] and be
like this guy's [__] amazing uh so
yeah I hope he went he was he was my
favorite thing about the movie it's
incredibly wellmade Chris Nolan is a
genius obviously um but he was what I
was most drawn to in the movie uh number
five Spider-Man across the spiderverse
yes of course so fantastic um I I I went
on this podcast and say that this is an
amazing achievement I don't love it as
much as I loved into the spiderverse and
I still don't but I rewatched it again
recently and like most of my problems
with it have faded away and I just kind
of am Gob smacked by the fact that this
movie exists yeah and they keep breaking
computer animation to a way that's to
all of our benefit like and I I was
watching this video essay about it and
they were like up until into the
spider-verse the Quest for animation was
reality we want to be photo real we want
if there's a submarine in Finding Nemo
which should look like a submarine in
real life if there's a there's a car in
The Incredibles too which should feel
like a car in real life everything was
shiny and beautiful and whatever and
then spiderverse movies came along and
they had to break computers to do art
that didn't want to do art and they were
animating it in weird ways like on the
ones and the twos and the three threes
where you would skip frames and like all
of this stuff to make it feel handmade
which Pixar is at the Leading Edge of
just making it look perfect and they're
like we don't want that we want it to
feel like there's a bunch of guys with
pens and drafting tables breaking their
souls to make art for you and that's
what across the spiderverse feels like
um beautifully put give it up for Mark F
eloquent as
always um I was just going to say like
it's [__] cool Spider-Man though
spider Punk though um Number Four The
Last of
Us the series not The Game the series
not the game which premiered in January
of this year which feels like a thousand
years
ago um but it it it could just be the
best video game adaptation ever made it
could just be one of the best zombie
movies ever made or it could just be one
of the best TV shows we saw a year and I
think it's all of the above right um I
think the ways it told its Story the
ways it took Liberty with the source
material and the fact that it gave us
that kind of story that we've seen now
like 19 times before which is grownass
man and child having to escort said
child to safety and found new ways to
tell that story and breathe new life
into that story um it is Lone Wolf and
Cub for sure but it's also a Lone Wolf
and Cub that will take an episode away
to tell you this adorable sweet
harrowing scary gay love story that kind
of has nothing to do with the Lone Wolf
Andor the cub and just give you some of
the best TV you've ever seen so last of
us 100% number four Barbie
yeah Barbie number three Barbie number
three is Barbie four was Last of Us
number three is Barbie absolutely
wonderful and singular I was thinking
it's so weird and it's going to sound
filthy I was thinking of a Barbie in the
shower this
morning uh and I was thinking like you
have no penis yes I was like I'm like
Ken down there um no kenergy whatsoever
I was thinking like what a singular feat
and
like that was in somebody's head yeah
and she got it out we know who said it
was in Greta gerwick and she got it out
and we're all the better for it it's a
wonderful [__] movie so fun so human
um and you know it's so good at its job
you forget that it's a 2-hour commercial
for a
doll at the root of it that's it do what
you will say what you will but it's like
it's produced my Mattel yeah but [__]
it's a piece of art man I hope she uh I
I hope she she's definitely going to get
nominated
um I mean you know it's going to win
Oscars yeah I just don't know which ones
other than probably best song I don't
yes I mean either Billy ish or Ryan
Gosling is going to win for that both
will perform at the Oscars which is now
worth the price of admission I don't
I don't know who I I mean like I got no
horse in the race and [__] but it would
be cool if she won for best director
yeah um there's a great I know a lot of
people online are like no it's got to be
Chris Nolan I mean he's also a genius
and [__] this going be a weird tight
race those kids all summer they were
like barbon Heimer and then during the
Oscar is going to be like [__] you to
death probably not they seem very
magnanimous it is profoundly odd though
for the two most popular movies of the
year to also be the two best movies of
the year yeah especially the two best
American movies of the Year true um that
is again not in any way knocking anybody
else who's on the list but that rarely
happens yeah you know you rarely get the
most popular thing also being one of the
best things yeah um so so yeah there's a
great interview um variety has a series
called like actors on actors and
directors on directors and it's James
Cameron talking to Greta Gerwig just
about like ultimately how big a fan he
is and like watching James Cameron like
alpha male Super Hyper masculine dude
just gush over Barbie and Greta G like
yeah man we made a [__] Barbie movie
and it's great and here's all the things
that I wanted it was always Ryan if Ryan
said no we didn't know what we were
going to do cuz he's the only person we
saw in our heads for that role um and
just talking about like you said we saw
it in our heads and con pulling it into
reality and how working with Mattel and
getting them to buy on into making
Mattel the bad guys of the Mattel movie
um is kind of astonishing it's a special
film and and truly one of the biggest if
not the biggest phenomenon of 2020
movies in
2023 um it is however not the highest
movie on this list oh number
two yeah it's the
flash uh number two is Rebel moon no
it's not Rebel
Moon it is definantly not Rebel Moon you
guys I I saw Rebel Moon and it's not
Rebel Moon um Godzilla minus
one really
um Brett Deacon our good friend Brett
Deacon who works at 40x and always gets
us tickets and got us tickets again
tonight to give out when we do the Q&A
uh he said he couldn't be here tonight
but he said I'm around all holidays and
I have a 40x and a three uh uh no what's
it called screen X version of this
Godzilla he goes so if he's I hav't
watch if you want to come over and watch
it yo do you want to go yes how good is
it which version though Mark you've seen
it so do we want screen X or do we want
4 do we want a chair to [__] us or what
um I I I think I think you want to get
penetrated by a moving seed um let me
ask you this yes a lot of human
parts yes [__] but but it does the thing
that almost none of these movies do
which is actually makes that story
compelling it makes it about grief and
responsibility and tragedy and and and
sort of come up in and earning one's
Place back in the world because it's
it's it's set in 1954 it's set after it
said it's like a prequel to The too
movie Godzilla minus one it's won year
before um and it's about it's about this
this kamakazi pilot who's unable to go
through with it and so he he does not do
his part in the war like he thought he
was supposed to do he does not
contribute to the glory of of mother
Japan like he thought he was supposed to
and like a c
flies away from his formation and lands
in this tiny Island base that Godzilla
attacks and he's now sort of pair bonded
with this giant beast and every time he
sees it he realizes that like he's not
man enough he's not human enough to be
worth living in this world he not only
survives the kamakazi stuff he survives
the Godzilla attack and goes back to the
mainland which is the disaster Zone
because it just finished World War II
and half the people have been bombed by
nukes and it's this is a Godzilla movie
it's a Godzilla movie because like every
time Godzilla comes into this guy's life
it takes something from him and it
happens with Fair regularity and the
Godzilla is scary it's horrifying throw
up the picture again they play it he's
got to find it sorry um but it plays
like a horror movie every time he shows
up like he's uh here we go and is he CG
yeah and apparently they made this movie
I don't quite believe it but the budget
for this movie is apparently $15 million
holy [__] and it looks better than any
Godzilla movie you've ever seen like
they legit destroy Japan the way you're
supposed to Wi a Godzilla movie and it's
harrowing every time it's harrowing no
connection to that Monarch show none at
all um but like it has the reasons why
Godzilla does the thing it does are in
the movie the reasons why he goes from
just being a giant T-rex to being a like
atomic fire Blaster are in the movie The
the ways that Japan try to get back on
its own feet after World War II and deal
with a Godzilla it's all there like it
it does the thing that I didn't think
you could do which is give me a Godzilla
movie about the people that I care about
and then also give me a Godzilla that's
[__] badass Jesus yeah no it's it's
it's the best movie I've seen all year
I'm uh definitely
[__] texting Deacon to be like I'm in
set me up and it's it does not crack two
hours
really that's what he's happy about I'm
very excited by that should have led the
review with that don't bury the lead
next time uh and the number one best
thing that I saw in all of 2023 here we
go
kids everyone's jerking off all of a
sudden and so loudly like Duck lotion
you guys um blueeyed samurai oh you you
loved it and that made your number one
spot that made my number one spot Mark's
been talking about it for a while now
I've been talking about it for like a
month I tried to get Luke to watch it
and he was like whatever um he's like
I'll watch more um but it's phenomenal
there's there's nothing that that show
does not do well it's a character piece
it's vicious bloody awesome Revenge n
it's a historical document of sort of
15th century Japan it's the most
beautiful show I've seen in a God's age
because it's all expertly crafted by
some of the best people who to do it and
the writing is such that it makes me
weep every time I watch it and I've seen
it more than once because I'm I realize
how bad I am at this job when you see
somebody do it that well oh was that
right and it's the kind of thing where
it suddenly becomes oh I need to not go
back to all the stuff I'm working on now
and steal from Blue Samurai and find
ways to to to just continue to peel back
layers of character and every time you
peel back layers of that protagonist it
it enriches the story and it's a
surprise if you think you know what
you're getting you're not getting it you
thought you knew you're not it always
subverts what your expectations are and
the action is out of this world how many
episodes eight how many people have seen
it so far put your hands
together that's your homework go home
what are you doing here
uh that's it number one on Mark's list
man uh let's go through the list real
quick number 10 Guardians 3 what was it
Guardians 3 Guardians 3 number nine
Pokerface number eight Leave the World
Behind number seven Scott Pilgrim takes
off number six Oppenheimer number five
across the spiderverse number four Last
of Us number three Barbie number two
Godzilla minus one number one blueeye
Samurai I think I've seen half your list
we did all right this yeah not bad
normally I'm like I don't hear that that
sounds cool um look at that man uh
there's a Year's worth of entertainment
right there give it up for Mark
man give it up for Hollywood they made
us cool stuff they did they entertained
um I got uh something that I'm going to
share and then we're going to share it
with the audience I
guess you grab
that
uh so you know they send me [__] all the
time and whatnot um this came from the
folks at Panasonic let's see what they
said hi Kevin we're handwritten yeah it
is handwritten damn um we are delighted
to present you with this limited edition
Stormtrooper inspired
shaver word in the galaxies you've taken
a ride aboard the Millennium Falcon and
you left feeling 10 years younger I said
that a few years back but yes now it's
time to welcome you to the dark side um
this shaver promises a similar
experience meaning it'll make me look 10
years long younger uh enjoy these Star
Wars inspired grooming Treasures May the
shave be with you the Panasonic team uh
so some lucky consumer tonight is going
home with
this it is a Panasonic shaver specialist
Edition uh rechargeable shaver that
looks like a
stormtrooper JC will you throw it into a
close camera and [__] so folks can see
that um there's other [__] in the Box as
well including a bunch of Keels shaving
stuff for the shaver presumably then
there's a Funko Pop with a bobblehead
bobblehead Funko Pop concept series
Stormtrooper MH then there's
uh a lanyard I guess it's got a bunch of
Stormtroopers on it and what looks like
a jerk off
towel oh yeah that's a jerk off Tow and
it's got a stormtrooper on it so you
know you could shoot straighter than a
stormtrooper uh right into that and then
you came in that thing you're braver
than I thought nice um the box is empty
there's nothing else in and [__] just
wrapping so we'll give those out uh
later on when we do the Q&A man but in
the me time thanks Panasonic for sending
some free [__] somebody's going to be
walking with with this shaver I see JC
is eyeing it right now he's just like
why didn't he just [__] give it to me
yeah you see my head I need a
shaver he's like I shave my head I own a
[__] Star Wars kind of
bar I really should should have just
given it to you my bad I
mean JC want to shave for everybody give
it up for JC I was going to say I was
going to say he does shave the he's
literally wearing a mohawk and I'm like
gee I wonder who would want
this I'm sorry it's not jar jar theme
but we could do um this was manscaped
who did not sponsor this episode but we
could do a next show we could do
Panasonic and we could compare and
contrast I'm G to get oh Panasonic just
texted please don't do
that this side of my head has been
manscaped and this side I'm my head is
Panasonic touch my head do you want the
jerk off towel as
well he looks like he really wants the
well I mean you want it but [__] you
got one he brought one with yours have a
storm tuber on it somewhere to aim if
you will we'll do it later on man then
there's a box of heels and [__] shaving
stuff and this stuff we'll give out
later but we're not even there yet we're
not we still got news we still have news
Mark Bernard has gathered news for you
everybody give it up for Mark in the
news I'm I'm going to I can't wait for
you no do them all and get to my
favorite story first oh you know my
favorite story involves Reacher
Reacher's back
kids anybody can I talk about some [__]
I watched go for it it's your show I
watched Leave the World Behind and we
talked about that I've watched the first
three episodes of Reacher they dropped
the reacher season two three episodes
they put up there it continues
to be a spellbindingly wonderful show
that interrupts my relationship with
Batman because as I said last remember I
watched it Mark once again this is a
show Mark was like you should watch
retro I was like whatever and then I
watched I was like Mark have you watched
reer um what I said then and it holds to
for this season I keep saying it out
loud you know as I watch it I'm like
this [__] guy makes Batman seem kind
of silly cuz like he beats the [__] out
of people no cape no [__] mask and
he'll kill you he has no [__]
provocation about that he's not like I
can't cuz of my parents he's like [__]
you
snap and I was like you know I remember
watching Reacher season 1 and then going
to see the Batman and for the first time
in my life I was like why would you wear
a mask like that it doesn't seem
practical at all you can't peripheral
and [__] like that but there's a story
that broke this week that Allan rich
richs richson is his name who plays
Reacher and he's fantastic in the show
but he literally wants to play
Batman that makes my life perfect cuz
then I go from Reacher to Batman I'm
like I believe them both because of the
actor and [__] I mean my only problem
with that is he's a great Batman but if
that dude puts on like a tuxedo and
shows up at a Gala to raise money for
the Wayne fation like oh it's Batman in
a
suit he's 90t T he weighs 400 lb you're
as big as Batman just a coincidence I
don't know what you're talking about um
yeah I I support it though man [__] cast
that guy's bman I love Reacher I think
he's so good in it he's so Charming has
anybody watched Reacher season 2
yet so [__] good and it's set in New
Jersey so it's like Reacher in New
Jersey I'm like oh I came like that lady
before man I was like
oh um anyway anyway that's the news
story that I was most excited about
Reacher wants to play Batman hopefully
James Gunn is listening and he's like
let's let him play Batman uh well
speaking of a guy who wants a job
there's somebody who's now out of a
job oh oh yeah uh the thing we all
thought was going to happen the minute
he uh ended up in court um Jonathan
Majors is now officially out as Kang the
Conqueror yeah they well they now that
after they after the verdict came down
verdict came down in in the case against
him and then Disney didn't seem to
hesitate I don't know if they've
released a statement or somebody they
have not because Disney rarely does that
so then why do they who knows how do
they know that it's it's been confirmed
by both Hollywood Reporter and deadline
have independently confirmed it which
means they called Disney who said yes
but but Disney's just like we're not
going to say it we're not going to talk
about this we don't want to talk about
it but we'll not say this not true um so
yeah that that's a dude who if there's a
way to Fumble a bag he he found every
possible way um it looks like uh they'll
be moving on from Kang you know like
probably but then again you could just
recast him like you know would be great
I think who what Terrence Howard
as oh my Lord that actually would be
kind of poetic next time baby here I am
K I'm a coner
man um likely not right like it seems to
coincide with all the people like all
the talk about like they got to change
they got to do something different yeah
so it smells like Kang Dynasty's going
away and the next two Avengers movies
are going to be oh come on yeah they
want you drunk they want your son to see
you inebriated tness is like one
more um you have somebody to drive you
home tonight six
more I'm not letting him drive my car in
the
rain also spoken like a guy who sells
drinks for a living man have six
more um where were we uh yeah well they
there was a a report a couple months ago
that internally that yes they
were what is up what was up
there give it up for Andrew man he's
he's always working back
there um that that Marvel internally was
always has already been debating what
are we going to do about Kang even
before the trial was just like it's not
hidden like he did not make a splash in
Ant-Man 3 which was a movie that nobody
liked he's not quite popping on Loki
season 2 which for any number of reasons
people loved or didn't love but the the
Kang part of it was never the thing that
people responded to and then and they
had already began referring to Avengers
the Kang Dynasty as Avengers 5 yeah like
they sort of like we're not going to
call it K we're just going to see what
happens but it's probably not K they
could still do K if they wanted to do K
you can recast which is 100% possible
they've done it before they can do it
again but it feels like post Ant-Man
it's
like it it's also like why why are we
why are we even entertaining this if he
if we've already seen him and he's not
doing what we need him to do um
especially when it seems like you know
the world is not as fervently interest
interested in Marvel's Cinematic
Universe as it used to be and stuff and
it's like you want to move along the the
X-Men of it all the Fantastic Four of it
all the Dr Doom of it all like give them
something to be excited about classic
characters that they've not yet handled
cinematically so this gets them closer
to it I would imagine yeah less
preoccupation with like Kang and more
with like you know big heavy hitter
characters they got sitting on the bench
that they paid a lot of money
you know to pull out of uh when they
bought Fox so yeah I mean if you need a
Multiverse there's a dozen ways to get a
Multiverse you don't necessarily need K
to do it and also the audience doesn't
really feel that jazz by a Multiverse
they don't seem to be into it I mean
like everyone was into a Spider-Man like
uh you know that was fun but it seems
like as they got deeper into the
Multiverse Saga what we've seen what
happened people just aren't biting as
much so get to Secret Wars man that's
something very easy to say like you know
all your favorite Heroes they fight each
other it's like Civil War [__] we did it
already uh speaking of a character who
will not be played by the actor again
Jason Mamo is pretty sure that he's done
playing Aquaman yeah there have been a
lot of stories this week uh um where
like he I watched an intro he did on
Twitter to some screening they did in
town at the Grove I think last night or
the night before and it it didn't it
sounded more like pour one out
for for all of this you know it didn't
sound like oh [__] let's celebrate it
sounded like you know we've reached the
end of the road right um they didn't do
a
Premiere they did some kind of fan
screening at the at the Grove but and he
was there and so was James uh the
director but they didn't have a
traditional Premiere I mean they still
have time because it's a Christmas movie
so it could be next week if they wanted
to but I don't think they're doing it
sounds like they don't want to spend the
money there's also that and they've
embargo the reviews until the day it
opens which is always a good sign means
it's great um I just don't understand
this is a movie that like made a the
first one made a billion dollars but
same with uh Captain Marvel first one
made a billion dollars and the sequels
like which historically sequels to very
successful movies at least do couple
hundred million dollars or you know now
it looks like that may not be the case
it's weird man but a lot of people point
to like well it's a movie in a universe
that's dead there's no like how can you
be invested because the story is not
going anywhere any further and I'm like
well back in the 70s and 80s that's all
we did was invest most things didn't go
anywhere we we had no expectation a
universe would be built around it and
stuff but uh yeah poor one out for for
Aquaman it doesn't seem like it's going
to light the world on fire been a bad
year for the superhero movie man it has
been it has been uh meanwhile over at
are you going to see it though yeah by
the way Aquaman 2 coming to SM Castle
Cinemas bring a friend please yeah like
listen I saw the flash so if I saw the
flash then it seems like my bar is
incredibly low for the DC stuff I'll go
see so that was this year as well f it
was yeah um on the other side of the
aisle um Disney has announced um a bunch
of new things in their anim slate okay
um they announced uh and they showed off
some things they did a Premiere or
screening event for what if season 2 and
then they showed like a teaser of things
that were coming next um one of them was
um friendly neighborhood Spider-Man um
cartoon the cartoon which was previously
known as Spider-Man freshman year right
um they showed a Sizzle reel for X-Men
97 which is like a direct continuation
the X-Men car of the X-Men cartoons and
they announced the show with some
footage called eyes of of
wakanda um almost nobody knows anything
about the eyes of wakanda um including
you know anything about it I
do I wrote two episodes of it so I I
know some things about eyes of
wakanda you allowed to say now I I can't
say anything besides that or the snipers
will get
Twitchy um why why are you allowed to
say that now because the information
they talk about the show yeah he Mark's
been sitting on that [__] for a long
[__] time if you go back and watch
like one of our episodes where he kind
of obliquely refers to it and [__] I
know the best part though was um before
I could talk about this at all there was
the Marvel Black Panther game that I
worked on that's right it was like I did
a thing with Marvel and like so it must
have been the game right and I'm like
yes it must have been the game um but no
this was a this was a pandemic gig this
was the reason why I couldn't come back
for Master season 2 right because this
swallowed my life for about nine months
um but I can't wait till you guys see it
because it's so [__] dope now this is
an animated series it's an animated
series um did you get to see any designs
in advance or no I did I did like in in
during the process luckily the the
showrunner was very sort of inclusive
with us and would kind of show us like
here's the design for this character for
that character here's some early
animatic stuff here's how this is going
to cut together and it all looked so
[__] great I can't wait now is Ryan
involved with that show he uh I I don't
I think that's
I I don't know I don't know there you go
that's probably maybe maybe not it's
it's hard to believe that's huge though
think about it dude you work for the you
you've worked for the big two you've
[__] written for Star Wars twice now
right mhm and now you've [__] written
for Marvel I have indeed give it up for
Mark man that's awesome well
done so so you said you wrote two I
wrote two I can't say anything else
about it other than what they've already
released yeah read it which is uh eyes
of wakanda will focus on Warriors from
the mystical and super scientific
African nation who've been quote tasked
to travel the world retrieving dangerous
vibranium artifacts end quote I can't
say anything else about what the show's
about but it's really really dope b b
man everybody can I ask you a question
about that then no
so about your experience Okay so rewind
many years we did uh several podcasts
and events here when Black Panther came
out uh that
winter uh and it was a lifechanging
thing for you it was a huge marker in
your life mhm and then you went and you
wrote for that character in that
universe so you got to play with the in
that thing it would be like me writing
Star Wars
right did you cry what what is that how
do you process that and anger as a human
no it's like the last seven years have
been incredibly surreal in that um most
of the work that I do especially in
television but also in comics and video
games at this point is stuff that I
loved when I was younger like getting to
write Star Wars comics is insane getting
to write the words interior Enterprise
Bridge Jean L Bard walks on is bananas
you know because next Generation in DS9
was mother's milk for me when I was like
15 years old and that was the show that
I watched you know like I I love Jason
Bourne so I got to write a Jason Bourne
show like I've I've been luckily enough
to walk through these worlds and find
some some way to tell stories that mean
something to me it is always insane it's
always surreal it's always like the
pinch me moment of did we just do the
thing that we've always wanted to do
yeah and did we get them to give us
money for it yeah this is a don't tell
anybody else so they'll want to do it
too um it remains a a singular odd
experience um it never gets regular it
never gets like oh it's just another day
playing with my childhood it's always
incredibly odd but totally wonderful and
also a little frustrating it always is
we're like but I want to do this and
like you can't do that but why can't I
do that oh cuz there's guard rails and
stuff like that there's always guard
rails there's always I mean with Marvel
there's guard rails with Star Wars there
guard rails with you know even writing
DC Comics that I owned there were
guardrails of things that like you just
couldn't do at DC um you got to go to
vertigo for that kind of freakiness um
so it's it's always a finding your way
to not just do the stuff that you loved
as a kid like I just want to play the
toys the way I always played with them
the way I saw them play that made me so
excited but always be reverent of those
toys because it's like man like this
means something to people and the fact
that it does means that there's a
responsibility to those people of which
I am at the front of that line and so as
long as I can be truthful to the younger
me who fell in love with it then I feel
like all right we we earned our paycheck
this week [__] it I give it up for Mark
man beautifully
P
um that's that's I can't wait till
you're allowed
to so much F oh my God we're going to
dive deep that's you're spy in the house
of love
man you're inside [__] marble uh all
right what's the next news story and are
you in it uh I am not in it this this is
a science story okay we don't do very
many science stories but you know we
like science fiction so why not also
cover science true uh in science news
Voyager one might have become
sensient
remember Voyager yeah verer from [__]
Star Trek the motion picture indeed uh
did he become sentient in that movie it
it did it did Star Trek coming true it
always does [__] um V NASA's Voyager One
space probe has started sending
nonsensical data back to Earth after
making a journey of billions of miles
and traveling for nearly 50 years in
space first launch in 1977 the
spacecraft was originally on a 5-year
mission to fly past Jupiter and Saturn
and then just kept going as of 2023
signals from Voyage of want toly take
more than 22 hours to reach Earth but
NASA says that the probe which is
currently 15 billion miles away had
suffered a quote Communications
glitch it has three onboard computers
that include flight data that collects
information about the spacecraft
scientific instruments and Engineering
data which is like a coded health bar um
and showing how Voyer one is doing and
on Earth we receive the data in binary
code um but now the probe is repeating
itself sending the same bit of code over
and over again leading scientists to
suspect it's broken it's not broken
Kevin there's
aliens and they've hijacked Voyager One
and it's warning us that they're coming
and all those binary codes not according
to the news article but according to me
are just saying help I was going to say
what's it saying man got to be like
[__] rod yes to serve man is all that
it keeps repeating back um I kind of
love the story because it's one more
thing to be afraid of yeah voyagers
coming back and it's and
piss you sent me
away I won't be
ignored uh I want what's mine um finally
um The Last Story which last news story
of 2023 n l n lose story last n wakand
of forever one more drink for Mark unas
um the great Andre Brower yes passed
away last week oh man we had to end with
a sad story we always have to end with a
sad story at 61 years old after brief
battle with lung
cancer um I so brief that were you aware
no I was shocked when the news came out
I was like what yeah I had no idea but
people go through things and they don't
always share it believe me if I was
going through a thing you'd [__] know
it some people suffer with dignity and
and don't share that news um what an
amazing actor this cat was yeah I mean
he had the the two great TV roles um
homicide life on the street and Brooklyn
99 he was histerical in it I mean he won
an Emmy for Brooklyn 99 did he yeah good
because I mean the it's so remarkable
for a dramatic actor to step into that
kind of role and just and kill it was
like legit funny kill it kill it kill it
for you know for six seasons of just
being phenomenal and the butt of every
joke the punch line the straight man um
was just terrific and he's been a he's
been in some nerd stuff over the course
cuz if you could have a career like that
then of course you're going to cover
some nerd stuff the Mist um the Mist he
was in the rise of Silver Surfer um he
was in the two Min series about one the
Salem's Lot and Andromeda Strain in 2004
2008 he was uh also the voice of dark
side in Superman Batman apocalypse oh
[__] I didn't know that yeah and he was
in the Jackie Chan Adventures cuz I
think everybody was
what he was I first saw him in glory
which is his first movie o did we just
log
in um and he was he was always this
actor of immense power but complete
control you know he always knew where he
was going he barely controlled rage was
a thing that he did incredibly well not
quite the righteous indignation of
Denzel but just this feeling of stifled
Fury that he was barely keeping a lid on
unless he was being hysterical or unless
he was just being like a dude like cuz
he did that show with Ray Romano I think
men of a certain age which is just this
kind of like amiable dramedy on like TNT
or whatever when they wanted characters
and he was great on that show he's great
in everything that he did and 61 is too
young to have a year where we lose both
Lance reic and Andre Brower these two
sort of Titanic voices um but also black
actors of a certain age who could do
anything they wanted to do and always
did it well how old was he
61 it's criminally [__] young man
yeah it's a shame and give it up for the
great Andre the lake great
[Applause]
Andre that is the news man think about
it
like we proably we saw his entire career
no yeah I mean we're old men so 100%
it's a shame man Julie are trained
really
yeah um [__] oh yes make make us happy
again I have a I have one news story
that made me very happy good um I grew
up a Transformers kid love Transformers
and uh that's why of course you opened a
Transformers
bar well users never seen it transform
into a different kind of yes it's true
um do you know what we're going to
actually we're going to put in the above
the front door we're going to put a sign
uh that says Hol so we're not so the
whole thing is fake so basically that's
the entry and this is the hollow deck so
this isn't real yes way to [__] Disney
dude a Disney lawyer on the planet can
[__] stand up to that argument it's
like oh it's a hollow deck yeah and
meanwhile Paramount us theol defense
Paramount's lawyers are like is it time
it's time now we move
in um but uh Peter Cullen the voice of
Optimus Prim Optimus Prime got a
Lifetime Achievement Award from the
National Association of Television Arts
and Sciences the emys gave him a
seriously a yeah he got a Lifetime
Achievement Award that's really sweet
man which I thought wasw yeah this a cat
that's been like involved wasn't he the
in the movies as well yeah so jeez has
anybody ever voiced Optimus Prime but
Peter cin very first epode was not Peter
Cullen and but after that it's always
been Peter
Cullen the animated Netflix one was not
him robots
dis Transformers robots in Disguise
though he was always
it apparently I'm not the only
Transformers yeah [__] we found a few
man night um well that's that's [__]
awesome good for him man I want to know
who those other voices were though like
Peter Cullen is so recognizable I bet
you somebody here who is the voice in
the first episode o transform and
R you want to go that way no no like
let's get somebody else quick in uh in
the new animated movie that's coming out
Transformers one it's Chris Hemsworth is
going to voice Optimus is doing the
voice of Optimus Prime no no love
Hemsworth but why why is Peter Colin not
doing this I I don't know whoever's
doing the it's an animated movie they
were like we wanted to try something
else yeah sure Cullen was like run me my
money it's like we don't want to pay
that Cullen money yeah we do have
Hemsworth money oh well congratulations
is Jack Black win an Emmy as well for uh
Kung Fu Panda which he apparently will
never not do the voice of Po even it was
the TV show for I think he's he's just
always GNA be that voice um and then Al
something else
won that was like oh Muppets Mayhem that
I was in they won an Emmy it was
cancelled two weeks ago but they won an
Emmy proving Disney once again way on
top of [__] knows what they're doing uh
but congratulations the good folks that
made Muppets Mayhem mu Muppet Muppets
Mayhem that's what it was called sounded
weird when I said it out loud um all
right no news all done that's it Q&A
time for Q&A kids we're going to talk
about uh [__] you guys want to talk
about before we do that though I brought
a host of
t-shirts that I'm just going to give
out uh now mind you these aren't like my
t-shirts or they are in as much as
people gave them to me but now they're
going to be
yours um this is a Chicago ComicCon
t-shirt 50th Edition who wants it throw
your hand up in the air
bang um herbarium is a weed store uh
that doesn't exist anymore because they
change their name to Cavill land and me
and Jay are all over the [__] walls
of the place because they make our
Caviar Gold weed our snoochie bis our
snans and our Berserker uh so this is a
shirt from the old place when it was
called herbarium extra large who wants a
weed
shirt bang right there um this is a 100
shirt which has the hundreds bomb on it
uh right there yeah look at you wearing
a hundreds thing uh this is
a h was
it TI
done go to him he doesn't even know what
it is and he wants
it give me uh this is a a uh I don't
know who it it's for but it's a company
called what's it say Comics pinball
Comics pinball and on the front it says
revenge of you know it oh it's cool it's
a store where in Glendale yes anybody I
did a convention bang oh I've been to
that store I shot a thing there yeah
yeah it's a great store man [__] Dave
desalin took me there and uh this is
also a revenge of shirt right there done
and
done and that concludes the free shirts
portion of evening ladies and gentlemen
if you like that come to smok there's
one just like this is it's a character
smoking a joint right there t bang go
heads up went right past you coming in
hot um all right we we also have uh one
of the people who's in the audience
tonight brought in it's which is right
behind you the bus stop poster for the
flash to give away that's got Michael
Keaton on it yeah I think we found the
winner I don't know if it has it's I
haven't unrolled it Michael Keaton who
wants this [__] does it
have is it the Michael Keaton one let's
open it up and see all the characters
every character I mean you know how do
we it's rolled let's unroll it and show
folks what it look like uh that's what
she said trigger warning we're going to
show something from the
[Music]
flash uh can you unroll that
and uh you got more space on that side
and face that camera Andrew give us a
front that's Batman super I see Michael
Keon right there there you go look at
that it's a giant bu stop ad that's
[__] nice man could you imagine if
somebody walked into this place and like
gave that as a prize 6 months ago you'd
have been like I'll suck dick for that 6
months later you'd be like I really
overcommitted for that
poster um all right so we got that as
well [__] and we got you know the
Stormtrooper comtow we have the Storm
Trooper Pop we have Keels there's lots
of [__] to give away and I also have uh
copies of my Muhammad Ali graphic novel
messenger so you'll win that and Deacon
as as I said before Deacon provided us
with a bunch of [__] what's that
Guardians of the Galaxy hat mm Wonka
poster wonka wonka poster well Lobby
card I guess they call um that is a
flurin a stuffed flurin from the movie
that made Mark's honorable mention
list the Marvel's [__]
help there's something in there inside
of there sweatshirt yeah but there's
something in the sweatshirt or maybe
it's just a really big
sweatshirt Guardians 3 oh it's just
really thick and it has like a patch or
something it's Guardians the Galaxy 3
sweatshirt Guardians bottle opener there
is a guardian's bottle opener no
Carabiner it looks like yeah it's a
carabiner you could also open bottles
with it if you want probably and of
course two tickets no [__] four four
tickets man you get two tickets to a
screen X feature and then two tickets to
a 40x feature man give it up for Brett
Deacon and 4dx coming heavy many New
Year yeah my God all right so [__]
the questions that we picked tonight man
we going to walk away some cool ass [__]
and like the best question hoodie gets
the the sideshow Aztec Batman now what
is that what it is the Aztec Batman whip
it out is there a picture of it or
something I have that at home Jessie
Hernandez is Jesse Hernandez did it do
you want to take it out it's a cool
piece well he's opening uh Degan sent
over the info that until
Thursday at Regal North Hollywood Wonka
is in 4dx with a special chocolate scent
oh [__]
so you got 40x tickets whoever asks
questions and [__] um you'll be able to
look at that
man face the camera Aztec Batman it's so
[__]
dope it's gorgeous man gorgeous people
SES show thanks the good Folks at
Sideshow so that's going to be who gets
that uh we need a metric for that maybe
it's the furthest question asker
furthest question asker fair enough not
the best I can't get this poster back in
but you know it's there all right kids
lots of [__] to give away if you've
never been if you're at home and you're
like oh my God they give away free [__]
yes we do so make sure you come when we
do the show uh live of course we'll be
doing it here at this scum villain
Cantina in 2024 uh probably in January
and we'll be back at SM Castle Cinemas
doing it probably sometime spring
February March maybe we'll do it before
the cruise maybe we'll do the Ides of
Mark there it is Ides of Mark too um
okayo uh JC picks the question so that
me and Mark uh don't you know have to do
the Sophie's choice of it all you figure
out who we're talking to who's the first
one I uh I think the name is Roy aala
aala Roy where you at come on up Roy
give it up for Roy
man is it Roy or Ray Ray Ray AP give it
up for Ray well done de bamp Man Ray
Give It Up Ray
everybody hello Ray hey
Roy what do you got Ray if you could be
the Wonka of any type of candy or food
what would it be and how would you
design your factory if I could be the
Wonka of any candy or food what a great
[__] question I would be the Wonka of
hummus the least popular Factory no kids
want to go there man um I'm I'm pretty
damn good at Megan hummus from scratch
so I would be that guy I would be like
if you want to view
hummus uh the king of the chickpeas
they'd call me and
[__] uh yeah that's I go hummus you um I
feel like you need a thing that has uh a
possibility for variety right cuz you
can make a few different
hummuses you can they're all
paced um I think I want to be the the
won of pizza oh I think you got that's a
popular choice why didn't I think of
that [__] I think cuz you don't eat that
[__] anymore well I can eat pizza I just
can't be real cheese got to be like
vegan cheese and it's got to be like
cauliflower crust basically it's got to
be not
pizza fair enough I mean and of course
we would have the saddest vegan pizza
room in the factory where it's just like
a bunch of like that's where you'll find
Kev Smith what are you doing making the
fake cheese I got all the Sorghum powder
and gelatin and feels like cheese it's
not cheese though they do [__] with
cashews
now I mean they've been doing [__] with
cashews for a thousand years not it was
cheese true Suddenly It's cheese um
Pizza what an excellent [__] CH yeah
you got your your deep dish your
Sicilian your Square pies your white
pies you got all kinds of different
ideas and again everybody loves it and
and a kid would want to take over a
Pizza Factory abut no kid is [__]
like trying to beat other kids take over
a hummus Factory so Pizza is the better
choice we got a Hot Pockets room down
there oh my God you're absolutely right
and you get the teens and the 20s
somethings as well got them all [__]
hummus what was that thiing man I really
got to think harder on these before I
just spit out an answer I'm like I'm
good at hummus [__] you know what
crackers your crackers
Factory um great [__] question man uh
you get to walk with a bag take one of
these [__] bag give it up for for Ray
and a book and the
book take this take this take this you
could also do the pizza
rolls part under that I like there's 98
different kinds of pizz you got your
flat beds you got your Detroit style you
got we all know he had a superior answer
don't [__] rub it in man but I will
point this out you can do hummus Puffs
as
well
uh uh Vincent
soprano Vincent sopro give it up for
Vincent
everybody Vincent also yeah you typed
his his thing
up wow did you type it out in advance
well done Vincent yeah he made fun of me
last time for doing that is it like a
four-part
question what what was that is it like a
four-part question no it's one sentence
he just wants it to be legible and he
got chosen so good plan I also write
like six questions so did you submit
that put the odds in my favor good the
think of
questions uh so he picked this one so
who or what is on your 20 23 naughty and
nice
list who or what is on my 2023 naughty
and nice
list
um you go first I got to think of
something why do I have to go first
because I'm always going first when it
gets hard you go first uh which sounds
exactly as filthy as I [__] meant
it I feel
like now are these like real people you
want or like characters or anything from
2023 that anything from 2023 that you
loved and you hated so you're naughty
and ice from 2023 okay all right aside
from your
list um I my my nice list I guess I'll
say it was Comic-Con this past year um
it was kind of lovely to return back to
kind of
inform um where 100,000 people showed up
and it was very much a comic book
convention because everybody was kind of
on strike and so the promotional part of
it wasn't there the lines are on the
Block to get into Hall h to watch actors
sit on the stage and talk about the
movies that you'll see in three months
all that was gone it was about the books
again it was about Community again it
was about the the world of fandom in the
way that we kind of love it and being
able to reconnect with that after a
pandemic and after whatever was just it
was kind of wonderful to be back there
again um my naughty
list I don't know man I really didn't
like Rebel moon but um but it feels like
really tough to just tee off on it now
when Reb moon is that uh it's it's
playing at the Egyptian Theater you went
to the movies to see I went to the
movies to see it wow in 70 mm at the
Egyptian cuz that Netflix bought that
theater they own the Egyptian so now
soit they played a 70mm print yeah they
made a they struck a print of that movie
to show it the Egyptian they got all the
money don't they yeah um how'd it go uh
I mean the theater's
lovely I mean it's 100 years old it's
when's it when's it on Netflix uh I feel
like it's like Friday I drop Thursday
Thursday yeah early for Christmas what's
people what's then what's the word um
the word is um you word what's what what
is the rest of the world saying what are
you saying so far the rest of the world
uh there there's two parts of the world
there's the part of the world that does
not love Zack Snider movies or does not
does not subscribe to the Nutter way of
life they're like whatever and then the
people who do are like oh my God it's
like Lawrence of Arabia
right uh it is probably somewhere in the
middle but not closer to the Lawrence of
Arabia part of that conversation but I
ran into a guy who drove in from Vegas
on Friday to see a noon the first matina
because he just and he had the Zack s
jacket awesome and I was like I'm not
going to yuck your yum man if you
enjoyed that movie power to you you
drove from Vegas you must have left at
6:00 a.m. to get here by 11: to see this
movie at 12: that's love and I can't
detract you from that love I do not
share your love and he's like I know
I'll wait for the show um but uh yeah
I'm not going to do that because that
would be just kicking a
baby in the teeth that it doesn't have
yet um I don't know you go I got to
think of a nasty
thing nice uh who's on my nice list you
know there's a lot of people who
sacrifice uh a lot of their time and
lives uh to make
mine smooth and make mine happen and
when I go oh I want to do a thing like
they make it happen they help me make it
happen and stuff and when people dream
your dreams for and with you this is
about the most beautiful gesture in the
world
so um you know like there's so many
people in my life in this room of course
Mark J JC um Andrew um but people like
Jason's wife Jordan like literally
[__] runs our business and and does
it tirelessly while she's got two kids
you know she just had a kid this year
and stuff uh Chelsea who works uh with
us in our office and has for for years
um Luke Jake uh who work like at the
website and stuff Mike zapi and
everybody back at the secret stash uh
these are you know the nice people that
allow me to live the life that I enjoy
living uh boy Jordan who is my agent
manager the one who gets me jobs and
[__] like that uh and then this year you
know it's been a long this year is a
tough [__] year and if I had to pick
a somebody for the naughty list like I
probably put myself on it it was a it
was a tough [__] year for our hero
and uh one point uh we might remember I
was in h a facility you know I was this
was such a long year that I spent the
beginning of it at Sierra Tucson and all
the people there are on my nice list cuz
you know they saved my life and gave me
some technology to deal with a world
that sometimes feels overwhelming and I
know everyone feels that as well and I
just had the luxury and the wherewithal
to take time out and go fix my head and
they helped me do that so all those cats
at Sierra Tucson uh are on my nice list
I'm doing a show here today and feeling
[__] normal and good because of the
work that they did and they'll be the
first ones to say like you put in the
work but it was it was them they they
they saved me uh so yes thank you to
them
um uh Josh Rous uh who shoots so much of
our stuff um and and
uh helps me make my dreams come true
Jason Muse uh Ralph Garmin uh Andy
melrish Jennifer of course um you know
Harley even um Harley's boyfriend this
year Austin way on my nice list he's the
lead in the movie we made and he's
[__] phenomenal and he gave one of
these performances like while we were
making the flick I had young actors uh
like four kids in their early 20s and
stuff and they were all so [__]
serious like while we're making the
movie I'm like look at these kids like
there's at one point there's a fight
scene because there's always a fight
scene in Kevin Smith movie but not
physical people argue there's always
like a third act fight right um so
there's a third act fight in this and
these kids like poured themselves into
it like between takes they were like
psyching each other up and [__] like
that like it was a wrestling match and I
remember sitting there going like oh my
God like just pretend just hit the mark
and say snoochie bis that's what the
other guy does like [__] why are they
taking it so seriously and then I'd sit
there every day and edit the footage and
I was like oh that's why you treat it
seriously like they gave these truly
beautiful performances um and I've said
it before other places I'll say it again
the script that I wrote I like it but
it's not like the the it's it's not the
strongest script I ever wrote it's very
sweet um very warm but it doesn't like
[__] it doesn't do what Dogma does
doesn't do what even [__] James alen
Bob Reb booot does or clerks 3 or
anything like that it's more of a a
feels movie it's all about like what it
was like to be 16 in 1986 and love
movies and [__] like that so I always
felt like going into every other movie I
was like the script is the strongest
element we have I didn't give a [__] who
was in the cast I was like they all come
together because of the script script's
the best element this time out was the
first time I ever made a movie where I
was like the script's good but that's
not what's going to make this movie
what's going to make this movie is the
cast if the cast is [__] Charming if
the cast is effervescent and [__] that's
what's going to carry us and thank God
they did and not only were they charming
and effervescent but all that reality
all that anguish they put into like
[__] feeling things or having their
character feel things like panned out
like it it was a smart choice and [__]
so I told them all like while left and
post I was like you know kids when we
were making that movie I thought you're
all so silly for trying so hard and
they're like thanks I was like but it
really panned out like because of you
the movie movie is what it is it's only
be is what it is because of you so those
the kids uh which would be Austin Nick
Reed and Sienna they're definitely on on
my nice list this year as well uh Ron
who Shard our movie I could go on and on
and on man and all of you everyone at
home I put up a video about mental
health this year I heard from so many
[__] wonderful people I still hear
from people everywhere I go in real life
online about like thank you for sharing
that and stuff like that so thank thank
you to to all of you who've been uh
patient uh with uh me for the course of
the last year uh I went on a journey and
uh
and you know I think the ship has been
writed so to speak so thank you for your
faith for your support for the kind
words and [__] like that uh and top of
my nice list is my mom because I almost
lost her [__] three times this year
and yeah she went through some bad
[__] incidences in the hospital and
stuff and at one point they told us like
look into hospice care and I was just
with her the other day and she's doing
[__] great so she's the top of my
niess without her I don't [__] exist
so that's off to
M
um who's your
naughty um I it it's it's funny there
there's a version of this where I could
have picked both my naughty and my nice
list as the wga
strike which was the the nice of it was
the spirit was the camaraderie was that
feeling of a bunch of people pulling a
boat in the same direction for progress
and for Change and for advancement and
for Value um and then the flip side of
that was the studios was thep the
alliance of motion picture and
television producers who could have
ended the strike whenever they wanted to
and decided it needed to go 148 days to
make people hurt and that the level of
Cruelty involved in in
sustaining a a thing they knew they were
going to have to do it was a deal they
were going to have to make and the fact
that it took them 6 months to do it
feels somewhat
misanthropic um or naughty or or naughty
yeah uh and not good naughty um granted
we all have to go back to work together
and we have to be in rooms with folks
and we have to do business with folks um
but that that was a that was a stretch
of time when you know our our partners
had kind of broken Faith with what we
were doing and why we were doing it and
chose to punish us for standing up for
ourselves and you know that we do not
forget um sobering answers but true
answers in stuffed uh but a great
question awesome give it up thank you
sir for the soprano
single thank you you also got to give
that stuff away we will all right those
would be bone those would be honorable
mentions oh that's what we're doing
there's like nine of
them uh what do we got JC uh last one
Jesse Campbell Jesse come on up everyone
give it up for Jesse they just
did what are your what are your favorite
holiday
specials ooh holiday specials um okay
let's see I was a big ranking bass or
Bass how do you say it bass bass right
Bas for your face I know base uh Rank
and base uh bass bass fan uh when I was
a kid so that year of course Rudolph the
Red-Nosed Reindeer um uh and Santa Claus
is Coming to Town Year Without a Santa
Claus Year Without a Santa Claus but
also the Easter on so here comes Peter
Cotton Tail uh also the you know the
little they did Nester the longear
donkey that's right um so those are tied
directly into my childhood you know most
of them AED on CBS and had that special
thing
that where you're like oh [__] we're
going to see some quality programming
and it was followed by some holiday
[__] special that still lives in my
head and heart um you know I'd be right
now there's a documentary about the Star
Wars Christmas special that you can
watch online it's streaming you can buy
it I don't know where maybe it's on
Apple or something like that uh that
Adam Goldberg produced uh or is one of
the producers on and they go deep on the
Christmas special but I only saw that
once in my childhood cuz they didn't air
it ever again and then I saw it later on
in life when I had a bootleg copy but it
didn't like I don't when I think of that
I don't think of Christmas I think of
like wow [__] I can't believe they
said yes um so I you know it's mostly
the the rank and bass stuff even more so
than the peanuts stuff and I I was a
huge peanuts fan still am and watched
all that but the rank and bass stuff
that just it feels like a happy
childhood like it feels like you
know back then we couldn't watch what we
wanted when we wanted so you had once a
year to watch it they didn't rerun it
it's not like we'll run it again this
summer because it was holiday
programming so it was event programming
like must see TV you had to be there to
see it otherwise you were going to miss
it before the error of the VCR so that
ties deeply into my childhood when
things were a lot more precious now the
culture is very disposable I'm not
saying things were better then and
things suck now not at all but now you
have access to everything you've ever
wanted you know there was a time where
in 19 [__] 79 they played Jaws on ABC
maybe it was 80 or something like that
but it was like four or five years after
it was ever in theaters and [__] and
when it played on ABC I had a tape
recorder and I tape recorded the whole
[__] movie so I could listen to it it
was long before we had vhs's and [__]
like that everything you know because of
it was scarce and particularly holiday
programming which they would run
seasonally once and not rerun felt more
special and loomed large in my life as a
child and because of that they have
wonderful resonating memories now when
was the last time I watched a rank and
bass thing [__] easily pre- clerks
but they still live right here um not
enough for me to try to pass them on to
my kid when she was young because they
wouldn't have worked on her like the
[__] that she liked was you know she was
in a Pixar and [__] like that I'm like
look at these puppets she would have
been like [__] no so it's still
something that like I share with other
people my age um it quite like the the
peanut specials of my youth um they
didn't seem to translate as well to F
following Generations I don't know any
kids that talk about the rank and bass
stuff anymore even Rudolph the Red-nosed
reindeeer um so because of that that
stuff it burns brighter because it's so
[__] precious but again I don't want
this to be like oh man [__] like [__]
was better when I was younger I'm not
saying it's better it was just different
and it was special because it was rare
now you know they've now they just came
out with Urkel Saves Christmas which is
about I don't know 20 years late but
eventually they got around to it gives
me hope that in 10 years Jay and Silent
Bob will save Christmas as well but
there's so much for everybody y do that
yes like believe me once I saw Urkel do
it I was like we're next um like cuz
they'll play it every year true like so
true like every every music artist
whether they want to or not cuts a
Christmas album because you can never
tell like you could be Mariah Cary and
have the song that will always play or
just be like John Legend has four
Christmas albums none of them are great
but like they're out there because you
might want to hear him sing hark the
herald angel sing because he's got
decent voice like Bobby mcfarren has a
Christmas album because of course he
does don't worry it be
Christmas don't worry yeah yeah I'm sure
that's what it is um don't worry be
married good plan just do it do it
sooner or later do an hour long special
man just do
it point being though they'll cater to
every single appetite there is for a
holiday special now back then they made
one a year if you were lucky and chances
are they made a thing you just watched
it 10 years [__] straight um yeah so
that would be mine yours I will die on
the hill of Humanity's finest
achievement is the Grinch by Chuck Jones
wonderful like it is it's it's perfect
yeah you know it is it is some of the
best hey just craft wise some of the
best animation out there but story-wise
the the the Liberties it takes with the
original story The Voice work you know
thr ravencraft doing the singing Boris
carof doing the narration like all of
that stuff is so great um it's it has
become the thing that I have to see
every Christmas season or it's not quite
Christmas um meanwhile while the other
half of my family my wife watches all of
it like my DVR is filled with the
shittiest Christmas stuff you Christmas
it is like wall toall Hallmark Christmas
movies and all the rank and bass stuff
and peanuts and like even the like Prep
and Landing like the stuff that they
made in like the mid 2000s for those
kids who needed CGI stuff right like I'm
sure we're going to watch Elf 400 times
before in the next week week A Christmas
Story my wife has to watch s of music or
it's not Christmas because same for her
they only ever put that on TV during
Christmas and so it became part of her
Christmas spirit I'm like I don't want
to watch these young Nazis fall in love
She's like I have
to I have to watch it I can't do it
anymore but the Grinch How the Grinch
though Christmas is it always will sing
a song in my heart honorable mention not
a kids program Scrooged I watch that
every [__] year this is of my
favorite Christmas stories I I I mean
it's funny throughout but it's I I find
it incredibly emotional at the end and
I've tried to live my life like like
Frank cross Bill Murray's character in
the last 10 minutes of Scrooge like
where you come to the where you get to
that place where you're like I
understand like he's so jubilant that is
one of my favorite monologues in cinema
history and for the way I understand it
he ad liid most of it like just to the
camera and stuff I love Scrooge um in
any event great [__] question you get
a bag and a book come get it man give it
up for Jesse well done thank you um all
right uh no no no [__] put that you
got a bag in a but you don't get that
[__] greedy [__] it's
Christmas um for the Aztec Batman how
about uh let's do uh who came furthest
we can do that although that person then
has to carry it back with them wherever
they they came that's true I'm from New
Zealand well good luck get him that on a
plane all right who came
closest uh what do you think or should
we just vote on a
person
um I don't know what do you think Jason
yeah what it's your bar oh gosh um I
mean I'm sure it's scintillating uh
streaming online watching this on the
YouTube feed as we think about who
should get this present that nobody else
will
get oh not not in this I'm going to keep
my mouth shut say again I bid
$37 bid 30 we're not selling
it it's got to be a gift I let Let's do
let's let's do who came the F farthest
okay fair enough who came the furthest
uh all right who thinks they came the
furthest yeah anybody outside of
California we got a couple over there
Montana all right hold on put your hands
together if you're not from California
put your hands together real quick if
you're not from California
clap sounds like you're working this
table only I think so we got Seattle can
you beat Seattle originally is
originally Israel but you didn't fly
from Tel
Aviv and this is Montana Montana Seattle
can anybody beat
Montana no going once
twice
Virginia
Virginia that's the East Coast wait did
you come to California from Virginia or
did you come for
this just say
this um really boyfriend what part of
Virginia Virginia Beach Virginia Beach
all right I mean that's far man I think
that wins unless we got somebody
International anybody beating Virginia
Virginia going once Virginia going twice
sold Virginia well done you guys w a bat
azte
Batman so close I mean Virginia is not
close to Seattle but you were this
close um all right how do we give away
the rest of this [__] I don't know you
throw it yeah
uh who has who saw the Flash in
theaters who saw the flash two times in
the theater who saw the flash three
times in the theater [__] a man so
did I wait I could
win who saw it so there's two of you how
many times did you see it five what do
you
have do you want the flash hold on hold
on you've seen it five times come up and
defend this
movie that's how you win the giant flash
poster five times you must have seen
something people didn't as a as a big um
fan of yourself thank you and John
schnip you know John snip I watch Death
of Superman lives all the time yeah the
thanagarian snare Beast came to life it
did on film it did the cage was not
happy about it but it did and I love
that moment I love every little Easter
egg even though obviously the CGI has
issues but I just so they said I love
what they tried to do yeah what was your
favorite part oh just the scene yeah the
scene where we saw all the DC characters
even in their shitty forms but saw you
know all the the history of DC I loved
it um and if you had this would you sell
it on eBay it's it's going on a wall
this would go up on your wall proudly
Fring it are you serious don't it's
going to be expensive man I've framed
giant posters before and when they
present the bill I'm like why did I
[__] do that put it on theil on the
ceiling over your bed that's right
looking down at you forever man uh I I
don't want to think of Ezra that much
but I want to think of all the other yes
just look at Batman um it is I I I I
don't watch the whole movie but I have
gone back and watched all the Michael
Keaton Parts within the last month the
Keaton cut yeah if I was if I did the
Keaton cut if I did my list of 10 things
Michael Keaton Batman would have been in
the top five I I enjoyed seeing Michael
Keaton come back and play Batman again I
know it didn't work out but [__] I loved
it um is it going to work out for you
you win the poster give it up thank you
so much excellent
job if you need rubber bands there's
some rubber band yeah there's a couple
rubber bands we took off uh we got a
stormtrooper pop how do we do this Jason
Stormtrooper pop uh you mention take it
you mentioned uh disturbance in the
force which is the holiday special
docent there a documentary about uh the
Star Wars Christmas Special it's called
disturbance in the force who who in here
has seen it yeah yeah handful of people
okay uh uh
oh now trivia about disturb
trivia uh name one of the three people
who are in that documentary that was
filmed in this
bar I'm standing right here and you go
with Seth [__] green first you were
filmed at SM Castle I wasn't here you
Wen you were here for
you are you serious yeah you were at SM
Castle you were here for last
Blockbuster that's what it
was there you go he got all three Taran
Kellum was here and who is the other one
Bonnie Burton who was uh and I wasn't
here no no I feel like Nicholson in The
Shining I feel like I've always been
here um all right so somebody just won
to pop so Jeff gets the give it up man
Jeff won to pop
ke's ultimate shave collection kids
comes with invigorating uh Gel Cleanser
brushless shave cream smoothing after
shave cream and energizing non greasy
moisturizer man it's all for your
[__] who wants
that four things for shaving uh clearly
I mean anybody who shaves this
guy for Kevin Conroy you you're look
you're a winner without winning but take
that give it up for Kev he won that
man
this is a a I guess a lanyard or a
keychain and it's got Stormtroopers on
it who likes Stormtroopers
bang this got very like it's the jerk
like I'm not going anywhere without my
lanyard without my C towel without this
Funko
Pop and like he said we come to the ctw
kids yeah here's the CT um it's got a
stormtrooper on it um and it's from the
good Folks at Panasonic who I'm sure
like please don't call it a
comt who's the youngest person in the
bar what a there you
go you selfs serving
[__] hey new fan of the show I
hear you like Storm
Troopers he wants it I don't need it
Merry Christmas Mark oh thank you I I
don't have that kind of steming
anymore um and don't forget you have to
figure out what you want out a pair of
sneakers oh no
well um all right did we give out all
our [__] I think we gave out all our
[__] and we don't have anything else you
have your Vans back those are mine I
take those nobody gets my Vans [__]
that's it we're out of show we did it
how many hours was
that uh oh damn almost almost three just
shy three well we got to keep it going
till we hit
three just to go out on an even number I
would imagine um anybody else got
anything they want to ask before we get
out of here go ahead yeah
what you're you're eating
Airwaves I heard yeah and
then go ahead fire
away my question from earlier was um
similar to Die Hard with a holiday movie
lots of people like to debate whether or
not it's a Christmas movie yes what the
sci-fi or comic book story would you
said during a holiday what holiday that
um uh in the spirit of how Die Hard is
considered by most to be a holiday or
Christmas movie and stuff what holiday
would we choose to do to set a comic
book or superhero science fiction movie
during is that right i' do a movie and
call it Iron Man
yeah they already have that though at
Christmas but that's you know it's
debatable but it's at Christmas I mean
every every Shane black movie is set
during Christmas is set during Christmas
um let me
see Groot on Arbor
Day
nice um Sergeant rock on Veterans Day o
nice
nice uh not as nice as group but I mean
no it's really good it's really good um
all right well there you go we did it
look at that go ahead Qui volume I'm
When
developing than you read the you read
Koy loves Comics so you actually read
that comic and [__] um quick stops uh
volume two issue one it's it starts the
movie origin story I thought of that
like I started writing it uh like a year
and a half ago or something like that um
because I'd finished like the 4:30 movie
and the 4:30 movie was so squeaky clean
I was like I got to [__] dirty it up
so I wrote the movie story next um but
it's all predicated on one line from
Dogma which is uh when when Loki and
bleby walk into the movies boardroom and
Ben Ben's character bleby tells the
origin story of movie the golden calf to
the boardroom he's like movie the golden
calf created in 19 something by uh Nancy
griu uh kindergarten teacher and then he
goes on and that's it so that one line
is the basis for all four issues of the
miniseries it's the Nancy Griff story
and um it's so [__] up um the first
issue as you see ends in a real like
what the [__] issue two is even more
weird issue three is just [__] I
shouldn't have written it uh and Issue
four brings it home on a more human
level and stuff but uh yeah it has it
hasn't that name has existed since Dogma
but the idea for this only about a year
and a half ago you NC wantate Med
that's do I have any any other you want
extrapolate into NC because Comics are
SOG anything I want to extrapolate into
nc17 because Comics is so forgiven
meaning like how I took movie and and
turned it dirty yeah like depr
um
no I I got yeah no I got in so much
trouble last time for joking um no
nothing smart yeah thank you nothing
nothing whatsoever one of uh one of the
big questions in chat tonight and we
might not want to go there but um was I
guess Kanye sample Dogma did you know
this uh some I I haven't heard it but
somebody told me that uh there was a
track that uh was dropped him and
somebody else it wasn't just him by
himself um it was another artist as well
yeah I guess he sampled J and Silent Bob
from line from from Dogma with with Jay
talking I heard I haven't heard it yet
it's all over readit but I did see a
bunch of people online going like like
did they ask and I'm like
no uh so I don't you know I don't know
how Muse feels about it cuz it's his
voice um but yeah it exists out there in
the world well it wouldn't be you anyway
it' be whoever owns Dogma right well I
mean that's the thing it's like when you
sample a song you know who has the song
But when you
sample somebody doing dialogue in a
movie Yes somebody owns the movie but
then there's also the element of that
somebody's performance so is Jay like
really rich cuz
he's maybe I don't know if Jay has a
lawsuit on his hands or not I don't know
how that [__] works and stuff but yeah
it's uh it's his voice well I figure if
it's like music then it would be
whoever's got the publishing rights
right whoever owns the Masters yeah but
in music it's usually a musical hook
that has nobody's singing or nobody's
voice in it generally speaking depends
like Kanye's sampled Ray Charles in the
past like there's so who money there I
think depending on who owns that
particular Library the owner of the
library would be the person they'd have
to clear it with but if it's like Taylor
Swift Taylor Swift needs to Grant you
the license even if somebody has the
publ like let's say somebody owns Ray
Charles's publishing which I'm sure they
do and it may not be Ray
Charles don't you then also if you're
using Ray Charles's voice doesn't matter
who owns the publishing don't you also
have to ask the artist can can I use
your voice in addition to this specific
clip you are also a separate element I
don't think like when Michael Jackson
bought the Beatles catalog yes he was
the one they had to go to to get
Revolution for ads for all the
publishing for all right so like they
don't have to go to like Lenin or
McCartney or their Estates to get a song
to put on a Nike ad they just got to pay
Michael Jackson is that right yeah like
that's that's the ups and downs of it
like you get paid a fortune for it right
but you then give up control of it when
you do that uh Jason Muse if you're
watching you're
[__] there's no no money for
you uh I have a a sweet story all right
so I ladies and gentlemen bman with a
sweet story give it up for him he owns
the bar give it up for him right now I
uh my daughter we converted my garage to
like my studio and I have all my toys
and stuff in there for her it's like if
she knew what Toys R Us was that's what
my garage is and uh she went out and
wanted to play superheroes today and I
had the hardest moment in my life
because she pulled all of my superpowers
toys and wanted to play superheroes with
Batman and Robin and the Penguin vintage
editions vintage in my mint conditioned
Batmobile
um so it's that like moment of like oh
my God don't touch these like I got
these in 1984 stop it but it's also my
daughter wants to play with Batman and
Robin with me so we we played with my
superhero hero toys today for like 25
minutes look at that you grew
up that was your bar mitzvah today you
are a man because you were like you know
what let the kid play with these toys
daddy why are you crying isn't it fun
the best yeah just like no it's
not if I'm 100% honest I was like if she
breaks it I can buy it on E yeah that's
that was that was my now we live in a
world where it's like you could find it
again um you know but also you're going
to have to figure out you've got the
hero toys and then the stunt toys and so
you buy the ones that like this cost me
$4 and it's not the real deal it doesn't
have to be and then you keep the hero
toys in the closet yeah I yeah I need to
move them up higher on the Shelf what it
comes down
to um adorable yeah my kid did that as
well just last week she was
24 like you know exactly how valuable
they are she's like let's play
dad couldn't say
no um [__] I think we're done I think we
should get out of here I think we're out
of show did we hit the three hour
mark yeah yes hey we did it kids three
hours about an hour of quality but three
hours of quantity man yall have a good
time this
week have you all had a good time this
year
did you enjoy your last ever podcast
buddy he's never coming back here yeah
like what you what' you think of [__]
pops fire right fire it's a compliment
that's a compliment you can say when
it's good thing do we want to reveal the
comics that are in your comic
bag for for for
after should we stop the stream and then
I guess I mean I guess we could we'll do
that afterwards
okay um yeah that feels like we
housekeeping we can do that not on the
show people at home will be like what
the [__] going
on um you'll see I don't know if you've
noticed this week but the bar is clean
generally the bar is always filled with
[__] that we have to S we don't have to
but we do and stuff and we all made a
collective decision that we should
really concentrate on the show so that's
what we did um and I got to say
like you feel all right yeah it was
helpful to not be like uhhuh yes what
you know cuz you're sign and [__] only
if we could stop reading the chat I mean
that's the thing when he was like when
he mentioned chat I was like oh my God
like I normally like when we do the home
shows I'm riding chat but I didn't even
think how was Chad tonight
um they loved the show oh I got a lot of
crap for jar jar no surprising ly
uh a lot goes into the show yeah when we
do it live a lot more than when we do it
at home yes and people are like the mic
levels and the this and the that and the
this and the that I was like I got in
here we haven't done a show in seven or
eight months here and I think right June
or July right yeah yeah oh my God you're
right either just before just after
ComiCon every single piece of video
equipment needed like a firmware up date
and stuff and so like like I'm like we
got the show it's going to air and
everybody's like it [__] sounds
terrible and I was like I can't believe
the computer updated in time so outside
of that outside of that
um sometimes people complain like we
don't hear you as well but I also look
like Joe free show for Joe Rogan has 80
people who work on his show we have like
me and Andrew so like I kind of like the
home feeling of the show you know I
always when I think of you I think of
Joe Rogan
too guys same same just same podcast
Kevin's now on my naughty list for
comparing me to Joe
Rogan um [__] I I feel I feel like we're
stalling we we hit the three the clock
ticked over I know I guess we got to go
we're about to be pumpkins again um for
folks uh thank you at home thank you
everybody here in the room man we made
it another year with fat man
beyond
[Applause]
absolutely it's never
guaranteed it's never guaranteed it's
another year no and honestly like
it's it's really uh special I've talked
about liking the show so much but what
happens is and you get a sense of object
permanence uh when you do a lot of
things and you're like oh this will go
on forever and they don't everything has
its time and you know there are things
that I don't get to do anymore case in
point like I'm not I don't miss it I'm I
when it was over I was glad it was over
because I'd done it a lot but for five
years I interviewed people for IMDb at
Sundance and at San Diego ComicCon and
um I don't like miss it I'm not like oh
I wish I could do that again but lately
I've been like oh that that's a whole
era that's happened and done and I won't
go down that path probably ever again
and stuff but like how special it was
and stuff this is I don't take the show
for granted as much as I enjoy it I
don't feel like this will go on forever
this will always be there because I now
have so many examples in my life of
things that I thought would go on
forever that [__] didn't and so now I
appreciate them so much more while
they're happening because you never know
how long they're going to happen this
show makes me so happy doing it whether
we do it home whether we do it here
whether we do it at SM Castle um I truly
hope it never ends but I'm glad that it
ever happened at all and I was glad that
it happened this year because as much as
people may like to watch us sit around
and [__] talk about pop culture uh
it's therapeutic I need this show this
year and so I was glad it was here thank
you all for being a part of
[Music]
our our our dream of [__] talking
about [__] we have nothing to do with um
we could do it on a zoom we could do it
in the room we could do it in a coat we
could do it on a boat [__] he and we
will do it on a boat in like two months
excellent [__] point oh my God what a
hell of a segue uh ladies and gentlemen
in February are you looking for a
Christmas gift for some [__] Kevin
Smith fan you're like what do I get him
go on the cruise man jayen Sil Bob's
cruise is Q me and Mark are going to be
on it doing fat man uh Beyond there me
and Ralph doing Hollywood Babylon me and
Jay doing Jay and Sal Bob get old me and
Andy doing uh Edge vacation me and Jen
doing plus one uh plus we've got uh uh
Brian o' hallerin Jeff Anderson Jason
Lee Ethan SLE me and Muse a whole bunch
of cats gonna be on Jane Sil Bobs
Cruisers skew leaves from Miami goes to
Bahamas three days you go you come back
3,000 of us I think we're at 80 or 85%
sold at this point or something going to
be a good [__] time that's like right
around the bend uh so you can watch me
and Mark do this on the high seas we
probably won't be streaming that episode
because we'll be in international waters
and [__] which means we could have knife
fights um so you'll miss the most
exciting fat man beyond of all time but
uh if you're into that sort of thing
kids you want join us on the high seas
go to J Bobs Cru escq uh.com and join up
and stuff well done well remembered
learn from the master thank you
uh come
on I'm I'm good I wouldn't I wouldn't
say um oh it what no I I was like am I
truly and then I was like no I'm I'm
good at it here I I'll tell you why I
pause I'm coming the word Master no did
I make it
weird no but you just did
that that hadn't occur to me oh my God
what occurred to me is I'm like I'm at a
weird Crossroads threshold point with me
and
podcasting uh because there's this
moment where I can lean
in and mind you I've been podcasting in
various forms since 2007 so I've been
doing it for quite some time um there's
a part of to me that's just like maybe
I've literally said everything there is
for me to say cuz podcasting is a
completely different world now um this
show is visual um but most of the stuff
I have done historically has not been
it's just been audio and you know I've
been sitting there going do I like is it
time to step back you know
like if I recommit it's like okay I'll
interview all the same [__] people
again which I've been doing for years
and years' or maybe this is like I I've
I've done it a bunch like this we can
keep doing but like whether I start a
new podcast or not I I don't know it's
just something I've been thinking about
lately and I used to think I was very
good at this um and sharp and and stuff
like that and and speaking on a regular
basis and do it in front of people and
whatnot made me sharper um I don't know
that I have anything new to bring to the
proceedings like when I started in
podcasting like nobody else was doing it
and it was easy to do new things and I
got to talk about [__] I always wanted
to talk about and I spent years
advocating for people to start podcasts
and they did everyone listened and now
the whole [__] world podcasts and at
that point it's like do I have anything
to add now when I started podcasting it
was never me going what do I have to add
I just did it for the joy of like what I
get to do this nobody will say no I just
record whatever I want with whoever I
want and stuff' but having done that
since 2007 which means I've been doing
it for 16 years at this
point maybe I've
reached the end maybe I don't have
anything to add to the medium and people
have picked up the ball and and ran with
it and they doing great with it and
maybe it's like oh I I was there in the
beginning and now I should just kind of
move on so it's something literally that
I've been thinking about for the last
four or five weeks going like where what
am I I going to do in the future about
podcasting and when you were like I
learned from the master I was sitting
there going like I I don't think I'm
that anymore like I don't and I'm not
saying this for pity or anything like
that I
just there comes a certain time when you
realize that like oh I've burned my
brightest in that area um that's as good
as it's ever going to
get um
and that's okay you know what I'm saying
and so I've been thinking a lot lately
about like not podcasting as much as I
did this I would always do because it's
easy he does most of the work I just
stand here and listen to [__] cool
stories and stuff but the other stuff
you know where in the beginning I did it
because it was like holy [__] this is
like keeping a massive diary but I've
been doing that for like 17 years and it
went off the rails in terms of being
about like my life it involves so many
other friends and like part of the joy
of podcasting was being able to shine a
light on people that I thought were
[__] special and funny and people
didn't necessarily know or something
like that and I've I'm like I pretty
much run out of people that I'm like
ladies and gentlemen this [__]
like I've introduced them all and and so
now I'm like maybe it's should maybe
that's it like maybe I don't have to
keep going you know and and and I
enjoyed it while it lasted maybe it's
time to push back from the table and be
thankful it ever happened at all so
anyway when you said I'm so sorry I've
been going through a thing and clearly
it's been on my head and heart and so
when he said the thing I was like oh my
God it's it's striking at the core of of
who I am right now in my existential
crisis about [__] podcasting well can
I tell you a thing yes uh when I said
that you are I learned at the Fe of the
master I was referring to you as a
Salesman not a
podcaster well that I am the master
at but also the other I also don't know
if I'm the master of that anymore I used
to be very good at selling one product
only Kevin Smith and I don't even know
how to do that anymore
um yeah
it's why is Oppenheimer up
there again not sad it's not like I'm
depressed or anything these are just
honestly what I've learned over the
course of the last year and what I've
learned over the course of podcasting
since 2007 is the cheapest form of
therapy there is always best to like
bring [__] out and [__] talk about it
because now I'll go home when when the
show's over and I'll get a thousand
opinions from a bunch of strangers most
of them will be like yes stop stop
talking but there'll be some nugget in
there which I'll be like ah there it is
yeah so sometimes it's look it's always
best to talk it out don't keep it in
kids over to b b he's got something to
say I was just going to say cuz I've
been doing jeez when did I started doing
Babylon and Jay and Bob get old with you
in March of
201 11 yeah so God we've been doing this
for 12 years yeah which is crazy so now
when I get asked to be on a podcast
about a bar or about Star Wars or
whatever I'm like how long do you need
me on and they're like we'll do about 20
minutes it's always 2 hours all right
because people are like tell me about
jarar Banks and then I sto talking like
to hours later I was like what's your
next question they're like we're done so
but that's the reason to do it because
in like in every other medium I work
it's all about brevity right it's all
about like keep it [__] short keep it
tight can't go on forever [__] has to
have a beginning middle end three a so
forth and so on uh when you're doing
press it's all about keeping it tight
and [__] what I've always loved about
podcasting is like there's no time limit
here like just go as long as you [__]
want and clearly we're going on hour
four right now and [__] so I like that
the freedom to just [__] Express like
you know I was one of the other things I
did in the course of the last week was I
went over Shannon dh's house and did her
podcast and it was lovely to see the
medium through her eyes again I've been
doing this since 2007 and [__] she is
brand new to the medium and she talked
about she's like this is better than
[__] therapy she's like I I feel hurt
I get to talk about things that like
nobody ever asked me about stuff and
that will always
be like intriguing to me freedom to
speak you know I've always held this
theory that human beings need three
things food [__] and to be heard and
podcasting the root of that has always
been to be heard I'm just wondering if
I've been heard enough and and that's me
saying it and I love the sound of my
voice so anyway that's where I've been
thinking but thank you for that that was
very kind of you to say that it wasn't n
podcasting you're right I'm a Salesman
first and foremost I said that to my kid
like [__] two months ago she was like
um something about like blah blah blah
you're an artist I was like I'm not an
artist and she's like yeah you are and I
was like no I'm a Salesman she's like
what are you talking about I was like I
just sell Kevin Smith she goes oh it's
so disgusting to hear and I was like why
she's like because you're supposed to be
an artist I was like oh now you sound
like the [__] internet let me be
whatever I'm going to be for heaven's
sakes and I'm still figuring that out
even at age 53 as I'm sure most of us
are are man it's okay to not know where
you are kids the important thing is
always be asking the question where am I
and uh you know I've been asking that a
lot lately for hopefully not in the
trunk of a car yeah [__] hopefully
true uh this show really [__] got off
the
rails let's take it off three hours now
let me tell you guys I don't know where
I am
anymore like he's having an identity
crisis right in front of us um ladies
and gentlemen uh kids of all ages people
everywhere did you have a good time this
[Applause]
evening uh thank you for being here man
uh give it up for uh The Man Without
whom we don't get to do a show in a very
cool looking bar look at this backdrop
[__] it's fantastic give it up for
bman himself
JC and Andrew in the box and Andrew in
the Box don't forget every time you see
an image up there looting us and every
camera change as done by Andrew give it
up for Andrew ladies and
gentlemen here at this comum vill
Cantina it's a bar they serve alcohol
they serve food and that wouldn't happen
without the staff give it up for the
staff and scull ability
Cantina ding ding ding uh but we got no
show without the guy standing to my left
ladies and gentlemen give it up for the
great Mark Bernard and
everybody thank you uh and there we go
kids that's going to do it man that is
fat man beyond for the year
uh I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernardin
tune in next year same fat Time same fat
channels podcast.com or youtube.com/
Kevin Smith big annual holiday Jeff's
kiss
[Applause]
everybody this is the m greetings
everybody and welcome to the AKA ask
keev anything every Saga has a 10year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and Silent
Bob get old up Kevin
[Applause]
Smith